Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 131. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich bin mal wieder unterwegs. Ich hab mich wegbewegt aus meiner Burg Berlin und hab mal eine etwas längere Reise angetreten. Und so, denn hier alles gut geht, werde ich hier auch gleich mehrere Sendungen hintereinander produzieren. Ich bin in Wien und freue mich hier sehr, einige interessante Leute zusammengetragen zu haben, haben zu werden. Ja, und den Anfang macht hier in Wien ein ja, ein Thema, was mal so eine ganz andere Perspektive auf die Computer nimmt, die wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag alle selber haben, aber eigentlich selten und viel zu wenig darüber reden. Es soll gehen, um User Interfaces, User Interaction, Design, ja, da gibt es bestimmt tausend Begriffe, die man da heranziehen könnte und jeder will sich seinen anderen und genau darüber möchte ich hier reden und zwar mit Peter, Peter Purgathofer. Hallo Peter.
Hallo.
Guten Tag, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Du bist, ja, was bist du?
Du bist? Genau, studierter Informatiker, wie man bei uns sagt.
Nicht abgebrochen?
Nicht abgebrochen, nein. Fertiggemacht, mit allen Ehren, mit einem Diplom und einem Doktor dann noch und einer Habilitation obendrauf.
Super, und dann bist du auch gleich in der Uni gestrandet.
Ja, so würde ich das auch nennen. Das ist passiert und ich würde es aber auch nicht mehr gegen irgendwas eintauschen. Es ist sehr selbstbestimmt und sehr, man hat das Gefühl, man kann was tun.
Und du wirkst hier an der TU Wien?
Am Institut für Gestaltungs- und Wirkungsforschung, sein Institut der Fakultät für Informatik.
Toller Name, Gestaltungs- und Wirkungsforschung. Das heißt, du forschst daran, inwieweit die Computer auf uns wirken.
Nein, das ist ein historischer Begriff, der kommt aus der Zeit, wo die Informatik hier wesentlich kleiner war und dann haben die Studenten, der Mittelbau und die Professoren miteinander gestreikt für den Ausbau der Informatik und der damalige Wissenschaftsminister hat dann verstanden, dass das irgendwie strategisch wichtig ist und hat die Informatik verdoppelt und plötzlich war die Frage, und jetzt, was machen wir jetzt mit den Stellen? Und dann haben sich die alle zurückgezogen, so der organisierende Kern der Studierenden und die Professoren und der Mittelbau auf so eine Seminarburg und haben dort die Inhalte festgelegt und da wurde den Studenten die Möglichkeit gegeben, diese Inhalte mit zu bestimmen und die haben dann gesagt, wir wollen Gestaltungs- und Wirkungsforschung. Damals war dieser Begriff noch sehr stark verknüpft mit dem, was man Techniksoziologie nennt, aber das war immer ganz explizit ausgeklammert. Techniksoziologie, das gibt es eigentlich auch nicht mehr. Das sind so Soziologen, die sich mit Technologien beschäftigen. Das tun inzwischen fast alle Soziologen, glaube ich. Und von dem her ist der Begriff auch verschwunden.
Aha, okay, Techniksoziologie, also sozusagen, wie soll man das sehen? Also wieso das gemeinsame WG-Leben zwischen Computer und Mensch?
Ja, genau, aber halt aus einer sozialwissenschaftlichen Sicht. Und die Idee hier war, etwas zu schaffen, was interdisziplinär, nicht nur sozialwissenschaftlich, aber auch sozialwissenschaftlich, aber auch geisteswissenschaftlich und auch aus der Sicht der Design-Disziplinen und aus der Sicht der Technik-Disziplinen an einem Institut verschiedene Sichtweisen zusammenbringt.
Aber ihr macht schon auch im eigentlichen Sinne Forschung an User-Interfaces?
Also es gibt verschiedene Leute hier, es gibt verschiedene Schwerpunkte, es gibt diese Makroebene, wo es um diese gesellschaftlich-technologischen Spannungsfelder geht. Wir beschäftigen uns viel mit Copyright, wir beschäftigen uns viel mit der Privatsphäre der Verschwindenden oder der sich Verändernden, wir beschäftigen uns viel mit der Verletzlichkeit, diesem etwas überwurzelten Begriff der Informationsgesellschaft und diesen Dingen. Und auch E-Voting war jetzt groß ein Thema. Bei uns gab es ja diesen eher verunglückten E-Voting-Versuch bei den ÖH-Wahlen, bei den Hochschülerschaftswahlen, wo ich mich sehr versucht habe, einzubringen und versucht habe, aufzuklären darüber, was das eigentlich für ein grober Unfug ist, der da passiert.
Ohne zu sehr darauf einzugehen zu wollen, aber verunglückt ist der, weil der einfach organisatorisch komplett gescheitert ist.
Nein, das ist er nicht. Er ist verunglückt, weil die Wahlbeteiligung noch niedriger war als die ganz braven und vorsichtigen Schätzungen des Ministeriums. Und weil es Universitäten gab, wo gar keine Studierenden e-voted haben. Die TU, da war der E-Voting-Anteil sehr niedrig, also noch ich glaube viermal so niedrig wie im Rest von ÖS. Also unter einem Prozent der Studierenden haben diese Möglichkeit wahrgenommen. Ansonsten, das Ministerium stelle es natürlich als großen Erfolg dar, weil es gab keine Pannen und es gab keine Probleme. Was sehr stark bemerkt wurde von allen Beteiligten war, dass die Diskussion über die Briefwahl nachgeholt wurde sozusagen. Da geht's eigentlich, gerade bei diesem Internet wählen, geht es sehr stark darum, dass es eine Form der Distanzwahl ist. Und Distanzwahlen an sich sind eine ganz kritische Geschichte, wo man sehr, ich würde sagen, wo man nicht einmal mehr vorsichtig sein muss, wo man einfach einen Riegel vorschieben muss. Distanzwahlen sind eine Schnapsidee. Da sind dann Fälle hochgekommen, wo es in England Gemeinden gab mit mehreren tausenden Geisterwählern, die eine Wähler-Evidenz, in der mehrere tausende Wähler eingetragen waren, die nicht existiert haben, aber die Brief gewählt haben. Und das geht nur, wenn man nicht hinkommen muss und seinen Ausweis herzeigen. Also das ist ein exploit, der aus der Form der Distanzwahl kommt. Und auch diese Wahlen in, wie soll ich sagen, in etwas hierarchischer, organisierten Subgesellschaften, wo der Big Papa kommt und die Wahlkarten einsammelt und dann für alle wählt, weil das dort so üblich ist. Also das sind alles Dinge, die aus dem Distanzwahlprinzip herauskommen.
Ist aber eigentlich auch ein User-Interface-Aspekt. Also ich überlege gerade meine Gutwirkungsforschung, da passt das sicherlich rein, wie interessant das gerade jetzt hier an dem Institut ist, so einen Schwerpunkt kriegt. Gar nicht so sehr jetzt von, wie sieht das User- Interface eines Wahlcomputers aus, sondern überhaupt, wie sieht eigentlich, man hat ja eigentlich auch mit einem abstrakten Ding zu tun, mit diesem Demokratiekörper, dem man dann irgendwie gegenüber steht und man ist dann so der Einzelne und muss dann so in kurzer Zeit eine Entscheidung fällen, auf Basis von was macht man das, wie präsentiert sich mir das gegenüber, was ist meine Interaktion damit?
Ich würde es unbedingt auch so sehen und ich würde es vor allem auch als eine Designfrage sehen, denn ich glaube, dass wir ganz dringend den Redesign von unseren demokratischen Prozessen brauchen. Und zwar vor allem auch unter dem Aspekt, wenn ich das jetzt ganz radikal formuliere, dass wenn ich mir diese Technologien anschaue, die von uns zukommen, dass auch das traditionelle Wahlrecht in mittelfristiger Zukunft vollkommen ausgehöhlt sein wird. Wenn ich einen Wahlzettel hernehme, den ich ausgefüllt habe und ich stecke in eine Maschine, die eine DNA-Analyse der darauf verbliebenen Restteilchen macht und dann einfach sagt, dass das mein Wahlzettel war, dann ist das Wahlgeheimnis eigentlich vorbei. Wir können gut versuchen, tief darüber nachzudenken, wie wir das umgehen, aber in Wirklichkeit ist diese Form von der Wahlzelle, in die wir hineingehen und dort wählen, ein Modell, von dem abzusehen ist, dass es kaputt geht, dass es unter dem technologischen Druck zusammenbricht, den wir gerade aufbauen. Da gibt es noch viel mehr Steck- Da gibt es eine Menge Dinge, die diese traditionelle Form der demokratischen Mitbestimmung über die Wahl irgendwie zerstören. Da müssen wir jetzt anfangen, darüber nachzudenken, wie wir uns eine demokratische Zukunft vorstellen. Ich glaube, dass in den neuen Technologien viel spannender Reformen der Mitbestimmungsstätten, als einmal alle vier oder fünf Jahre wählen zu gehen. Das ist ja eigentlich ein jetzt-sicher Unfug.
Direkte, flüssige Demokratie. Ja gut, aber das ist auch noch mal ein Themenfeld für einen eigenen Podcast und das nicht nur einen. Trotzdem ein interessanter Ausblick, aber jetzt wollte ich schon noch mal ein bisschen zurückkommen auf das eigentliche...
Wenn ich vielleicht ganz kurz noch sage, wir waren noch beim Institut und das war die Makroebene und wir decken dann diese Fragen von, wo Mensch und Maschine zusammentreffen, ab bis ganz ganz nach unten und wo es dann um die Frage geht, mache ich das jetzt besser rot oder blau hier? Also so ganz banale grafische Design-Fragen, die sie auch bei uns zu Hause gefunden haben im Rahmen der Informatik. Und da dazwischen steckt natürlich dieser Begriff des Interaktionsdesign oder, ich weiß nicht, Experience-Design scheint sich jetzt ein bisschen einzubürgern, wo es um die Frage geht, wie gestalten wir denn jetzt Technologien, so ganz allgemein, schwammig, wie gestalten wir sie damit, die Menschen gut damit arbeiten können oder gut damit freizeiten können oder gut damit tun, machen, was immer sie wollen können.
Schaffen können, schaffenswert sein können. Ja, es ist die alte Frage nach dem Mensch-Maschine-Schnittstelle, dem Interface. Wenn man mal so ein bisschen in der Geschichte zurückglättert, wo fing denn das an? Also was, wo siehst du denn so die ersten wichtigen Aspekte, wo diese Frage das erste Mal aufkam, wie muss ich mit der Maschine interagieren und wo ist auch die Art und Weise, wie es gestaltet ist, entscheidend dafür, ja, wie gut mir das gelingt?
Im Sinne dessen, was du gerade angesprochen hast, dass quasi auch diese Distanzwahlen-Frage eine User-Interface-Design-Frage ist, könnte ich natürlich sagen, dass das wirklich bei Adam und Eva anfängt. Bei der Frage, was dürfen sie denn und was dürfen sie nicht und dürfen sie von diesem Wissensbaum sich was holen oder werden sie dann vertreten, aber das ist glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit hergeholt.
Ja, steht auch auf schwammigen Grunden.
Nein, ich glaube, ein Punkt, da nehme ich immer gerne beginn, ist unweigerlich der Herr Newton, der mit der Differenzialrechnung, der als einer derjenigen gilt, die die ersten Rechenmaschinen gebaut hat. Da gab es ein paar andere, die haben schon Rechenmaschinen gebaut. Newton gilt als der Erfinder dieses Übertragsmechanismus. Wenn man sieben und sieben zusammenzählt, gibt es einen Übertrag auf die nächste Stelle.
War das nicht Leibniz?
Das war natürlich Leibniz. Wie peinlich. Leibniz war es. Ich verwechsel die beiden immer, aber das ist gut, weil man weiß eh nicht, wer die Differenzialrechnung ist.
Leibniz hat ja auch so das mit dem dualen System.
Ja, natürlich war es Leibniz. Nein, nein, nein. Und Leibniz hat damit eine Maschine geschaffen, die, wenn man sie sich heute anschaut, nur verwendet werden kann, wenn man sich so richtig gut auskennt damit. Das ist ein wunderschön Werk, ein präzisionsmechanisches Werk, wunderschön, aber unbedienbar, wenn man nicht weiß, um was es hier geht. Und hat damit im Grunde das erste Mensch-Maschine-Interface geschaffen, wo man Experte sein muss.
Ein wunderschönes Kupfer-Monstrum mit irgendwie Hebeln und vor allem Kurbeln ohne Ende. Großartig. Und was, also ich meine, aber wahr ist, ja, ich meine, ist das nicht, wenn man so etwas mechanisch löst, Rechnen. Ja, hier ging's ja überhaupt erst mal darum, ein Abbild zu finden dafür, wie kann ich den eigentlichen zu automatisierenden Vorgang, nämlich das Rechnen, in einer Maschine überhaupt bewerkstelligen? Steht dann schon das User-Interface von vornherein mit dabei oder war da nicht sozusagen der Bediener, der Büttel des Systems, was man erst mal gefunden hat, um das Problem überhaupt erst mal zu lösen?
Genau, das ist eine Frage, die sich bis heute in jedem Projekt stellt. Wo setze ich denn jetzt an? Muss ich mir nicht zuerst überlegen, wie die Datenbanken aufgebaut sind, welche Serverstruktur ich brauche und welche technischen Hintergrundsysteme ich brauche, um ein System umzusetzen? Oder muss ich darüber beginnen, nachzudenken, wie die Leute später mal damit schaffen sollen, kreativ oder produktiv arbeiten?
Obwohl man wahrscheinlich noch nicht so über so eine Heerschar von Bedienern nachgedacht hat.
Überhaupt nicht. Ich habe das Gerät für sich gebaut, für seine persönlichen Bedürfnisse. Ein spannender Randaspekt von dieser Leibniz-Rechenmaschine ist ja, dass sie nicht produziert werden könnte in größeren Stückzahlen, weil es das feinmechanische Wissen noch nicht gab, die feinmechanische Literacy, sage ich, unter den Metallverarbeitern, die das einfach nicht konnten. Und das hat Jahrzehnte, vielleicht sogar Jahrhunderte gedauert, bis das in größerem Maß vorhanden war. Und es gibt zumindest eine Theorie, die sagt, dass das die umgeschulten Schneider aus der Französischen Revolution waren. Also die Französische Revolution hat Schneider im Wesentlichen arbeitslos gemacht, weil diese Perücken aufgehört haben. Diese riesigen Perücken, für die man eigentlich einen eigenen Schneider hat. So wie man einen Battler hat, hat man einen Schneider für seine Perücke. Und die waren dann alle arbeitslos, weil diese Perücken einfach abgeschafft wurden. Und die waren aber feinmechanisch relativ bewandert. Und viele von denen sind dann Feinmechaniker geworden. Und das war die Voraussetzung dafür, dass es auch die Uhr in der Mastenproduktion gab. Und eben diese Rechenmaschinen. Da gibt es ein ganz wunderschöner Beispiel.
Die Rechenmaschine war sogar noch vor der Uhr?
Naja, das war so die selbe Zeit ungefähr. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, von wann ist die Uhr. Ich kann natürlich auch über die Uhr und deren Interface reden.
Ja, kann man in der Tat. Ich meine, auch da handelt es sich ja auch um eine interessante Abstraktion der Zeit, die es ja so irgendwann auch mal nicht gegeben hat. Klar, Tage in irgendeiner Form hatte man schon immer, Monate sicherlich auch. Aber jetzt wirklich so weit zu gehen, dass man einerseits die Sekunde schafft, sage ich mal, oder auch schon die Minute ist, ach, schon die Stunde ist ja im Prinzip überhaupt Zwölfer-Aufteilung oder 24er-Aufteilung. Weiß gar nicht, wo kommt das her, weißt du das? Weiß jetzt auch nicht. Aber gab es da einen langen Weg zu dem, was man heute kennt?
Ich glaube nur, dass man schon festhalten sollte, dass die Uhr als Technologie gewaltige gesellschaftliche Veränderungen verursacht hat. Und zwar wirklich verursacht. Manche sagen, wir sind das Klave der Zeit geworden. Es war nicht mehr möglich, zu sagen, ich komme, wenn die Sonne am höchsten steht und das war halt dann so, da bin ich dann nicht mehr gekommen, sondern das war jetzt plötzlich ein absoluter Zeitpunkt. Ich glaube, dass es schon vorher Sonnenuhren gab und andere Uhren und die mechanische Uhr war dann nur noch die Perfektion, die es sozusagen den Hebel groß genug gemacht hat, dass es wirklich diese Veränderungen greifen konnten. Aber in Wirklichkeit weise ich darüber zu wenig.
Ja und vor allem auch das Prinzip einer öffentlichen Uhr, also die Kirchturm-Uhr und dann später halt eben auch die ganzen Uhren, die da rumsteigen. Gefühlt nimmt es ja gerade wieder ein bisschen ab mit den Uhren. Früher habe ich immer so hier unseren zentralen europäischen Kontinent immer vor allem dahingehend unterscheiden können von anderen Ländern, dass so viele Uhren rumstanden. Jetzt mit dem Aufkommen vom Mobiltelefon nimmt das auf einmal wieder ab.
Es gibt so eine ganz drollige Studie aus Japan, ich glaube schon zehn Jahren jetzt, wo sie Jugendliche gefragt haben, was denn die beliebteste Uhrenmarke ist. Und die Antwort war überwiegend Entity Docomo. Das ist der staatliche Telekom-Provider.
Weil die überall ihr Logo drauf haben?
Nein, weil die Leute das Handy als Uhr haben. Entity Docomo ist der Provider des Handys auch.
Das ist Ihr Uhrenhersteller?
Das ist Ihr Uhrenhersteller, Entity Docomo. Da sieht man auch den Schaden, den Apple gerade in der Mobilkommunikationsbranche anrichtet. Denn das ist der erste Hersteller eines Geräts, der den Mobilkommunikationsfirmen die Kundenbeziehung stiehlt. Denn ich habe nicht mehr ein Handy bei diesem oder ihrem Provider, sondern ich habe ein iPhone von Apple. Und damit bin ich eigentlich nicht mehr Orange oder T-Mobile-Kunde, sondern ich bin Apple-Kunde geworden. Und das ist ein entsetzlicher, entsetzlicher, so wie Fluten, die alles unten ausschwemmen und dann bricht zusammen. Ich würde das so sehen. Das ist schon sehr kaffiniert. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Jetzt kommen wir noch sehr ab von dem, worauf ich hinausreite.
Was jetzt spannend ist, wenn man diese Rechenmaschine vom Leibniz anschaut, ist, dass es in kürzester Zeit auch schon Visionen gab, was man damit nicht alles Tolles machen könnte, wenn man es nicht noch anders baut. Ich glaube, das ist eins der Dinge, die die Geschichte der Informations- und Kommunikations-Technologien sehr stark auszeichnet. Dieses Wechselspiel von Realität und unglaublichen Visionen. Da könnte man die Analytical Engine von Charles Babbage hervorheben. Der hat eine Maschine gebaut, eine sehr gute Rechenmaschine, die Difference Engine, die Polynome berechnen sollte. Polynome sind der Kern, der mathematische Nährboden, den man braucht, um Logarithmen-Tafeln zu erzeugen. Man rechnet lange Polynome aus und nähert auf diese Art und Weise die Logarithmen-Werte an. Logarithmen-Tafeln sind notwendig für jede Art von Mathematik, die nicht automatisiert abläuft. Multiplikationen macht man durch die Addition der Logarithmen und dann wird das exponentieren. Mathematik, irgendwie Schulwissen noch. Und da hat er diese Maschine gebaut, die automatisch durchs reines Kurbeln einfach ein Polynom nach dem anderen ausgerechnet hat. Da hat man lang genug gekurbelt und dann kam er. Und dann hat er darüber nachgedacht, dass man da eigentlich ein Gerät bauen könnte, das nicht nur rein so voreingestellte Berechnungen macht, sondern dass man diese Berechnungen programmieren könnte. Da gibt es einen Speicher, eine arithmetische Einheit, eine Kontrolleinheit, eine Ein- und eine Ausgabe. Und er hat ein Gerät entworfen, das ist eben diese Analytical Engine, die das alles konnte. Es gab Pläne und er hat versucht, jahrelang, er hat versucht, Geld dafür zu bekommen, um dieses Ding zu bauen. Heute weiß man, es wäre unbaubar gewesen zu dieser Zeit, die Reibungswärme, also die Kraft, die notwendig gewesen wäre, um das Ding anzukurbeln, um es auf dem Laufen zu haben. Hätte so viel Reibungswärme im Inneren erzeugt, dass Metalle geschmolzen wären. Man hätte Elefanten gebraucht, um dieses Ding anzuleiern und dann wäre es kaputt gegangen. Aber er hat die Idee zählt. Und dann gab es eben diese Lady Ada Lovelace, die versteht, was das bedeutet, mathematisch, analytisch und das erste Programm der Geschichte schreibt. Und das war damals das User Interface, das Programm. Und das wird lang so bleiben, dass man eigentlich programmieren können muss, um mit einem Computer umzugehen. Das ist ein Verständnis, dass, auch wie es dann Computer gab, noch lange Zeit eine Leitvorstellung war, dass man eigentlich programmieren können muss, um einen Computer zu bedienen. Und das alles, weiß ich, da kamen dann diese Fenster- und Maus-Geschichten daher und da gab es massive Kritik, dass das nicht ein nachhaltiges Verwenden eines Computers ist. Dass man damit eigentlich die Illusion schafft, die ein tiefes Verständnis der Dinge verhindert. Und das ist eine Kritik, die man eigentlich bis heute hört. Dass das so ein Bimbi-Fax obendrauf ist, ja. Genau, bunty-Clicky, das sagt sie ja in Deutschland. Und dass das verhindert, dass man versteht, was eigentlich wirklich passiert.
Ja, es ist ein valider Punkt, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass das eine das andere sofort ablöst. Man kann halt beides haben und von daher, das zeigt ja auch die Geschichte der jüngsten Entwicklung. Es verbreitet sich halt immer mehr. Es gibt halt immer mehr Leute, die jetzt mit Computern irgendwas anfangen können, die mit dieser alten, tiefergehenden Methode so nichts anfangen konnten. Insofern eröffnen sich halt neue Schnittstellen, die eben dann eben für andere Leute auch nutzbar sind. Ja, stimmt, das mit dem Programmieren, das hat sich lange gehalten. Also ich kann mich auch noch gut erinnern, als ich so das erste Mal so bewusst die Existenz von Computern wahrgenommen habe, da war es, also das ist so Anfang der 80er Jahre, nicht? Also da hat man ja noch so Ende der 70er Jahre, da war ja so Computer-Kaufen, wenn man sich selber einkaufen wollte, das waren ja dann so nackte Boards, die dann so bestenfalls eine Batterie von so DIP-Schaltern hatten, mit denen man dann so mit kleinen Tasten da Wort für Wort sein Programm direkt in den Speicher reinwerfen konnte. Das war natürlich schon sehr arkan, dann wenige Jahre später kam dann eben die Homecomputer auf, die aber auch an sich erstmal nicht waren. C64 schaltet man eben ein und was sagt er zu einem? Ready. Und was meint er damit? Ich bin bereit, deine Befehle entgegenzunehmen, die aber letzten Endes nichts anderes sind als Basic-Anweisungen.
Genau, man war auch direkt in einem Basic-Interpreter und hat eigentlich über Basic mit dem Computer gesprochen. Ob man jetzt quasi Zeile für Zeile ohne Nummern-Commands gesagt hat oder ob man sie mit Nummern versehen hat und dadurch ablaufbar gemacht hat, war dann eigentlich Blut. Was übrig geblieben ist, du musstest in seiner Sprache mit ihm sprechen.
Und er sprach auch in seiner Sprache zu einem.
Und das geht ihm zurück auf diese Analytical Engine und die Lady Ada Lovelastie, auch Namensgeberin für diese Ada-Programmiersprache, weil das ein Monster des amerikanischen Verteidigungsministeriums ist.
Was immer noch verwendet wird.
Was immer noch verwendet wird und viele meinen auch, es ist eine ganz ausgezeichnete Sprache.
Ja, vor allem ist sie beweisbar. Das ist glaube ich so eins der Gründe, warum es auch immer noch eingesetzt wird im Gegensatz zu den ganzen anderen populären Sachen, die nicht so ohne weiteres beweisbar sind.
Ich finde es auch immer wieder schön zu sehen, dass in den Wurzeln dieser so männlich dominanten Wissenschaft, da steht eine Frau und versteht als erstes die Maschine und deren Potenzial. Gibt es ein wunderschönes Zitat. Wir dürfen durchaus sagen, dass die analytische Maschine gleichermaßen algebraische Muster webt wie Chakras, Webstuhl, Blumen und Blätter. Hier liegt weitaus mehr Originalität als die Differenzmaschine, als reine Rechenmaschine je für sich beanspruchen darf. Also hier steckt schon ein tieferes Verständnis dieses Möglichkeitenraums, der im Programmieren liegt.
Was nicht so einfach zu erkennen war. Ganz sicher nicht. Vor allem, was auch immer sehr schwer bewusst wahrzunehmen ist, was auch noch, als ich dann so meiner Mutter gegenüber das erste Mal den Wunsch geäußert hätte, ich bräuchte ja unbedingt in meinem Leben einen Computer, kam natürlich die Frage, warum in aller Welt sollte man so etwas brauchen und ich weiß noch, dass ich eigentlich gar nicht, ich war nicht in der Lage, Argumente aufzuzählen. Ich habe mir irgendwas ausgedacht, dass man da ja Notizen drauf macht.
Die Schallplattensammlung und die Bücher.
Soweit ging es gar nicht. Mir war einfach der Selbstzweck leuchtete mir irgendwie ein, aber der war natürlich schwer zu vermitteln. Blumen und Blätter, schöne Muster, die sich ja später in der Computerkunst auch wiederfinden. Allein diese ganze fraktale Erscheinung, das hat natürlich alles so seine ganz eigene Ästhetik. Aber das war ja nicht zu halten. Also ich meine, dass man jetzt wirklich auf Jahr und Tag wirklich auf dieser Programmier-Ebene mit dem Rechner spricht. Da gab es auch sicherlich auch schon früher andere Versionen.
Naja, es ist spannend zu sehen, wie sich das so nicht radikal, sondern so Schritt für Schritt erst davon weg entwickelt. Da gibt es dann, muss ich schauen, also vielleicht, damit wir das nicht überspringen, der Kern der Entstehung des Computers aus heutiger Sicht ist natürlich der Alan Turing, die theoretische Erfindung des Computers und die Turing-Maschine als das essenzielle gedankliche Konstrukt, das dahinter steht, die passiert im Versuch, die Nazi-Kryptographie zu knacken. Also sozusagen aus angewandter Kryptographie heraus. Aus heutiger Sicht finde ich das auch spannend. Die angewandte Kryptographie hat auch heute viele interessante Dinge noch zu tun oder schreckliche. Und da entsteht halt dieses, eigentlich das ganz abstrakte Konzept dessen, was ein Computer ist. Und auch das ist ein als gedankliches Konstrukt nichts, mit dem man irgendeine Form von Interaktion hat, sondern das eigentlich, indem ich das Problem hineinstecke und dann wurstelt es und es kommt etwas heraus. Es terminiert, ganz wichtiger Punkt bei der Turing-Maschine. Und von dem her verschwindet das dann sogar noch eine Ebene weg von durch das mathematische Herangehen von Alan Turing, spielt quasi die Interaktion überhaupt keine Rolle mehr, sondern es geht nur noch darum, hineinstecken und herausbekommen. Und das ändert sich natürlich radikal im Kalten Krieg, wo das Potenzial von Computern versucht wird zu nutzen, um die Bedrohung, also vor allem in den USA, von Sowjetungen wissen wir zu wenig, also um die Bedrohung des atomalen Erzschlags in den Griff zu bekommen. Und da gibt es also ein System, das historisch hervorsticht, sowohl durch seinen enormen Aufwand als auch durch sein enormes Scheitern, das ist Sage. Da kann man sich ganz wunderbare Dokufilme auf archive.org und im Brelinger Archiv anschauen. Da gibt es einen Doku, eher Propagandafilme, die also von Sage erzählen. Und das Besondere von Sage war, dass es quasi die Etablierung des Bildschirms war, die Etablierung der Interaktion mit dem Bildschirm. Da gab es vorher schon so kleine lustige Experimente von neugierigen Technikern, die so Spiele gebaut haben. Tennis for Two, ganz berühmt, das erste Computerspiel, eigentlich gar kein Computerspiel, weil es kein Computer war, sondern dafür zusammengelötete Elektronik und Space Wars, glaube ich, hat das geheißen von...
Space War war ja eigentlich wirklich das erste Computerspiel.
Genau.
PDP-Zeiten. Aber vielleicht noch mal kurz mit dem Message, da können wir gleich noch mal drauf eingehen, aber beim Touring, es gibt auch diesen Touring-Test, der so feststellen soll, habe ich es jetzt mit einem Mensch oder habe ich es jetzt mit einer Maschine zu tun. Ist das nicht so ein bisschen auch so das Modell, wo sich im Prinzip auch quasi der Unterschied manifestiert und ergibt sich nicht quasi aus der Betrachtung des Unterschiedes auch automatisch ein Design für die Schnittstelle, wenn man unterscheiden kann, hier fängt der Computer an, hier fängt der Mensch an, oder hier hört der Computer auf, hier fängt der Mensch an und vice versa, dass man quasi damit ja auch den Ort auslotet, wo eigentlich diese Mensch-Maschine-Schnittstelle tatsächlich stattfinden sollte? Oder ist das ein bisschen zu weit?
Nein, da ist schon was dran. Ich würde es so sagen, dass die Vorstellung damals unter den Visionären war, der Computer als eine kommunizierende Maschine, als ein Denkverstärker, sag ich jetzt mal, der mir beim Lösen von Problemen hilft, indem ich mit ihm spreche. So ähnlich, wie man das eigentlich in den Star Trek Next-Generation-Folgen ganz gut immer sieht. Das wäre jetzt eine dramaturgisch ausgeformte Version dessen. Man sagt dem Computer, was man will, er macht dann Vorschläge und man tritt in einen Dialog. Also diese Vorstellung des Dialogs in Form einer Kommunikation zwischen Mensch und Maschine war damals die erste Leitidee, an der sich die Gestaltung der Systeme orientieren wollte. Nie wirklich dort hingekommen ist, weil das eine Vorstellungsteam wir bis heute nicht im Griff haben, mit Maschinen in irgendeiner sinnvollen Art und Weise kohärente Gespräche zu führen.
Wobei der Mensch, der schnell auf den Leim geht, dieses kleine Eleizer-Programm von Walzenbaum gezeigt hat.
Richtig, aber in einem sehr speziellen Domain. Wenn man über Electrical Engineering reden würde, dann würde die Sache schon ganz anders ausschauen. In dem Sinne war ganz klar, es gibt sozusagen mich und es gibt den Computer, aber als Vision gab es schon auch dieses Verschmelzen, dass die Kommunikation dann so selbstverständlich funktionieren kann, dass man gar nicht mehr redet, sondern dass man sich einfach direkt zusammenhängt. Also das findet sich schon ganz früh, ganz am Anfang zurück. Und dann kamen eben Steve Russell und seine Freunde vom Tech.
Aber dieses Sage-Ding, was wir jetzt erwähnt haben.
Ja, da komm ich jetzt gleich hin. Also dieses Space War, wenn man jetzt auch einen kleinen Schritt zurückgeht, dann findet man modelleisenbare spielende Männer, den Steve Russell und seine Freunde vom Tech Model Railroad Club.
Im Prinzip der Geburtsmoment der Hacker.
Ja, oder des Nerds. Die haben auch schon alle so dicke Brillen auf. Und die nehmen halt so einen Computer und hängen einen, wie heißen diese elektrischen runden Dinger, diese Periskop, nein, Statoskop, nein. Oszilloskop. Genau, im Wesentlichen hängen die ein Oszilloskop dran und steuern es mit dem Computer an. Ein bisschen ein gehacktes und herauskommt ein Spiel, wo man also mit zwei Raumschiffen um eine Gravitationsquelle herumfliegt, von der man angezogen wird und versucht, sich gegenseitig abzuschießen. Und im Wesentlichen, wenn man sich Sage anschaut, steckt da noch immer, dort heißt das Displayscope und wird bezeichnet als eine Hochzeit zwischen Oszilloskop und Fernseher. Und ist ein großer runder Bildschirm, wo man mit seinem schweren Metall an ein Gerät hinzeigt und dann einen Hebel drückt, um eine Position dort zu bezeichnen. Wenn man sich das jetzt anschaut und ein bisschen zuschaut, wie das bedient wird, dann sieht man das auch dort noch, wie bei der Rechenmaschine vom Leibniz, jede einzelne Funktion eine Taste hat. Also es gibt eine riesige Menge, eine Batterie von Tasten rauf und runter. Und dass man mit diesen Tasten dem Computer eigentlich nicht Befehle notwendigerweise gibt, sondern auch Zusammenhänge zeigt, die er dann zu interpretieren hat. Und damit steckt man schon wieder ein bisschen in diesem Programmieren drinnen. Man verlässt quasi dieses mach das jetzt für mich, mach das jetzt für mich, sondern versucht ihm zu sagen, hier, schau mal, das passiert jetzt so und das passiert jetzt so und jetzt...
Ich habe das jetzt ganz verstanden. Also dieses SAGE, wofür wurde das eigentlich gemacht?
Es war der Versuch, ein System zu haben, mit dem man die Luftsicherheit behalten kann, den atomaren Erstschlag der Sowjetunion zu verhindern. Ja, genau. Das war ein bisschen unglücklich, weil die langstreckten Raketen, die so hochfliegen, dass dieses System komplett chancenlos war dagegen, und es heißt wohl auch, dass dieses System mehrere nahezu Gegenschläge gegen Phantom-Bedrohungen ausgelöst hat, weil es fehlen interpretiert hat, was da daherkommt. Hochfliegende Vogelschwerme und solche Dinge. Das ist ja schon so eine on-going-Saga bei den Amerikanern, nicht auch so mit dem Space. Genau. Und es war aber das größte IT-Projekt dieser Zeit.
Also 50er Jahre, ne?
Ab 54 wird es gebaut, eingesetzt wird es ab 58, vier Jahre in Entwicklung. Etwa ein Viertel aller jener, die sich in den USA zu der Zeit als Programmierer bezeichnen, arbeiten an diesem Projekt. Und da zeugen die unglaubliche Menge von 250.000 Zeilen Code, 300 Tonnen Hardware steckt dahinter, 10 Milliarden Dollar, wenn man das auf heutige Zeiten umrechnet.
10 Milliarden Dollar, ein Viertel aller Programmierer, Gott.
Also das ist schon ganz substanziell, ne?
Ich möchte nicht wissen, was dabei rauskommt, wenn ein Viertel aller Programmierer auf diesem Planeten mit seinen Denken an ein Code zuschreiben.
Ja, heute ist das.
Kein Vergleich. So, und dieses Display Scope war sozusagen der Versuch, jetzt für diese Luft abwehren, User-Interfaces zu schaffen.
Man muss sich das wirklich anschauen. Wenn man in dieses Brelinger Archiv geht, gibt es eben diesen Sage-Propagandafilm, der erklärt, wie groß das nicht ist, und der auch mit ganz spannender Musik hinterlegt ist. Also das ist sehr, sehr... Ja, genau. Der Display Scope. Das ist ganz rührend. Was man jetzt, wenn man noch ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen schaut, festhalten kann, ist, dass mit diesem System Strukturen geschaffen werden, die lange Zeit in vielen Bereichen vorherrschend sind. Sage war ein zentralisiertes System. Da gibt es diese große Sage-Zentrale, mit einem Betonblock, irgendwo gefüllt mit Technologie, mit diesen 300 Tonnen Computern. Und alles, was Peripherie war, war komplett passiv. Es waren nur Datenlieferanten und Befehlsempfänger. Und damit wurde zum Beispiel die Struktur geschaffen, die in der Luftraumüberwachung bis heute üblich ist. Luftraumüberwachung ist nichts, was dezentral oder vernetzt passiert, natürlich vernetzt, aber nicht so jetzt in vielen kleinen Stationen, sondern da gibt es dieses Luftraumüberwachungscenter England Südwest und das hat den gesamten Südwesten England über und macht dort die Luftraumüberwachung und gibt Befehle an alle Stellen aus, mit denen es zu tun hat. Das ist dieselbe Struktur, die kommt auch davon. Als solches war dieses System dann auch im Einsatz.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht war das Ding schon visionär. Es war als System als solches, als Investition ein Flop, aber das ist ja nun in der amerikanischen Technik-Geschichte sehr häufig, man hat also einen mega Aufwand getrieben, also allein Weltraumfahrt, Mondlandung und so weiter, was da für eine Intensität reingesteckt wurde, das hat sich natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht gerechnet, aber am Ende dann eben schon, weil sie natürlich auch frühzeitig schon Fehler gemacht haben, die sie dann später nicht mehr noch machen mussten. Wenn ich so auf den europäischen Kontinent schaue, da ist immer so eine ganz furchtbare Vorsicht, so und so, und dann wird dann auch irgendwann die Großprojekte gestartet, viel zu spät, aber auch auf die falsche Art und Weise und die Lehren, die daraus gezogen werden konnten, die werden dann eigentlich nie so richtig ausgeschöpft. Naja, aber dieses Displayscope, das ist quasi so ein riesiger runder Bildschirm, und wie war jetzt die geplante Interaktion mit diesem Teil? Also was war sozusagen, es ging schon um sozusagen den Überwachungsbildschirm, dass man so die Welt sieht und so.
Du siehst die Welt, du siehst dann so gepunktete Linien, wo etwas fliegt.
Also es ist mehr eine Visualisierung.
Ja, aber du hast dieses komische Ding da zu einer Pistole mit einem schweren Kabel unten dran, mit dem man auch nicht lange arbeiten kann, weil das so schwer ist, wo man eben hin zeigt und dann einen Knopf drückt und dann weiß das Ding die Position, auf die man zeigt.
Sozusagen dieser Lichtgriffel, der den Kartonenstrahl, der vorbeikommt, empfängt und dann den Zeitpunkt per Interrupt wieder an den Computer zurückmeldet und der weiß ja, wo er gerade den Strahl hingeschickt hat und dann weiß er eben, wo das auf dem Bildschirm war. Das ist ja auch später auf Homecomputer noch zum Einsatz gekommen.
Vorher sogar schon. Wie hieß denn diese erste Konsole da von Magnavox? Odyssee, genau. Also das war eine Geschichte, die nachher auch bei Videospielkonzolen eingesetzt wurde. Da gab es auch diese Kanone, mit der man auf den Fernseher gezielt hat und wenn man abgedrückt hat, hat der Fernseher weiß geblitzt und dann hat dieses Ding gesehen, wo der Strahl gerade war. Wenn das Bild schwarz ist, dann gibt es ja keine Informationen, die reinkommen. Also man muss, wenn man schießt, muss das blitzen und dann kann man messen, welchen Teil des Bildschirms man gerade gesehen hat, weil der Kathodenstrahl vorbeigekommen ist.
Wo waren wir denn jetzt eigentlich hängen geblieben? Also wir hatten über Leibniz und Thuringen und other lovelace gesprochen und im Prinzip hat sich herausgebildet, also der eigentliche Klassiker ist sozusagen, man redet mit dem Computer in seiner Sprache, die die Programmiersprache ist, die eigentliche Maschinensprache ist zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil mit den abstrakten Programmiersprachen dauerte das ja noch so eine Weile. Andererseits gab es schon dann, gut ich meine Thuringen, gut jetzt befinden wir uns im zwanzigsten Jahrhundert, in den 50er Jahren ging es halt richtig los, große Computer wurden gebaut, User Interfaces wurden ausprobiert. Aber im Großen und Ganzen waren es eigentlich immer die Kommandozeile, mit der man eigentlich es zu tun hatte.
Und noch immer diese Grundvorstellung der Kommunikation mit dem Ding. Wenn man Joonyx anschaut als Kommandozeile, dann ist es ja eigentlich auch das. Du kommunizierst mit dem Ding in sehr komplexer Art und Weise mit Pipes und Redirects, da kann man schon ganz faszinierende Dinge machen.
Hat schon auch nach Programmiersprachen Charakter?
Genau, ist ja auch. Shell, ist ja eigentlich. Na klar. Und wenn man jetzt schaut, es gibt da von Even Sutherland aus den 60er Jahren ein ganz faszinierendes System, das heißt Sketchpad. Und das ist wieder etwas, was ich sehr empfehlen kann, sich selber anzuschauen. Da gibt es ein Video, wo der Alan Kay erklärt, wie Sketchpad funktioniert hat. Der war offensichtlich beteiligt an dem Projekt, ich weiß das nicht genau. War auch ein Projekt mit so einem Lichtgriffel und mit so einer Reihe von Tasten neben dem Bildschirm. Und wenn man da zuschaut, der konstruiert da so einen rechten Winkel in diesem Video und mit einem Loch, wo man dann eine Niete hineinsteckt. Und wenn man dem zuschaut, wie er das erklärt, dann versteht man ganz deutlich, dass man eigentlich ein objektorientiertes Programmiersystem versichert, wo die Linien die Objekte sind. Und den Linien werden jetzt Eigenschaften zugewiesen, wie zum Beispiel ihr zwei seid rechtwinkelig zueinander oder ihr seid parallel oder hier ist der Mittelpunkt und du seid ein Kreis. Das heißt, noch immer steckt diese Programmier-Idee drinnen in der Art und Weise, wie ein Grafikprogramm funktioniert. Aus heutiger Sicht etwas ganz eigenartiges, wo man zuschaut und sich denkt, wie kann man auf diese Idee kommen. Aber als eine Fortsetzung der Ideen, die davor waren, eine ganz logische Geschichte, wenn ich mit dem Computer in seiner Sprache spreche, wenn ich ihn quasi programmiere, um Antworten zu bekommen, dann muss ich auch Grafiken programmieren, damit der Computer sie versteht und richtig umsetzen kann.
Das Sketchpad war im Prinzip so ein Vektor-basierender Ausgabe.
Ja, da war der Bildschirm dann schon viereckig und man hatte auch so eine lange Leiste von Tasten, die lag dann in einem Kästchen daneben, wo man dann gedrückt hat. Wieder war jede Taste ein Befehl, also das war auch eine Geschichte, die lange Zeit geblieben ist, die man sogar noch im Xerox Star findet. Jede Taste ein Befehl.
Das findet man auch heute noch bei Photoshop, die Kästchen.
Ja, genau, aber trotzdem ist es Software, denn welche Taste, das ist meine Angelegenheit. Also als Abkürzung ist es ja nichts Schlechtes, aber da war das Hardware, diese Taste war an diesen Command geknüpft. Und der LK war dann auch der, der als erstes von dem Computer spricht, der komplett nur aus Software besteht. Und nicht, also den man nur durch die Software steuert. Das war eine Vision, die er in die Welt gesetzt hat, kann man sagen. Und das ist ganz spannend zu sehen, nicht, da hier, they will have enough power to be entirely shaped by Software, sagt er, shaped by Software. Und das ist eigentlich das, was wir heute haben. Die Tastatur, welche Tastatur du da hintust, ist vollkommen wurscht. Welche Maus oder ob du überhaupt eine Maus brauchst. Ich kann genauso gut sagen, blinde Arbeiten mit Systemen ohne Maus, ganz klar. Und trotzdem können sie auf dieselbe Information zugreifen und dieselbe Software nutzen.
Wo das zusammenkommt zu diesem grafischen Aspekt und aber auch die Sache mit den Programmiersprachen, sind da so Systeme wie Programmiersprachen Logo, die ja so ein bisschen für, sagt man zumindest, für Computer, für Kinder entwickelt wurde. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt der erste Ansatz war. Also es wurde auf jeden Fall dann, also in der Homecomputer-Ära der 80er-Jahre wurde es vor allem, sozusagen, ist gut für Kinder. Ich fände, alle Programmiersprachen waren eigentlich gut für Kinder, aber das ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber da hatte man halt so diese Idee mit der Turtle-Grafik, nicht wahr? Man hat so seine kleine Schildkröte und die latscht irgendwie über so einen zweidimensionalen Space und zieht immer so eine Linie hinter sich her oder macht den Schwanz nach oben und dann hat sie eben keine Linie mehr. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch so eine visuelle Herangehensweise, obwohl man es trotzdem noch mit einer Programmiersprache zu tun hat.
Ja, und es ist in Teilen Schäd bei Software. Aber auch das ist wieder eine Programmiersprache, die noch drinnen steckt. Ich möchte aber schon trotzdem, ich glaube, man kann das schon so sehen, dass auch die Turtle und Logo auf das gedankliche Kind von Ellen K aus der Zeit zurückgeht. Ellen K hat damals eine Vision beschrieben von diesem Dynabook. Und das Dynabook war ganz klar eine Maschine, gezielt nicht auf Erwachsene, die arbeiten oder kreativ sind, sondern auf Kinder. Weil er sagt, der wesentliche Schritt ist nicht wir, die wir jetzt lernen, wie wir mit der Technologie umgehen. Der wesentliche Schritt werden die sein, die mit den Technologien aufwachsen. Und wir müssen jetzt schauen, dass wir denen Technologien zur Verfügung stellen, die eine neue Art von Denken möglich machen, eine neue Art von Tun, eine neue Art von Auseinandersetzung mit der Welt möglich machen. Und das ist dieses Deine Book. Das es immer nur als Pappendeckel, Karton-Prototypen gegeben hat, wo sie ausführliche Studien gemacht haben. Dabei macht er, ja, da waren wir nicht zu sehr. Also die, die, die, nicht? The computer is a medium and like the printed book during the middle ages has the potential to modify the thought patterns of those who are literate. Und das ist das, das war sein Plan.
Die Computer hat die Möglichkeit, die Gedankenmuster zu...
Zu beeinflussen. Wenn ich mit dem Computer aufwachse, dann denke ich anders. Und das ist was, was wir heute, was ich würde sagen, wir durchaus beobachten, dass die Kids, die heute an die Uni kommen, die ticken anders.
Ja.
Die ticken anders. Ganz, ich traue mir nicht zu, exakt zu beschreiben wie, aber sie ticken anders.
Was sind die Symptome?
Sie sind eigentlich, ja, was sind die Symptome? Ich würde sagen, eins, was ich feststelle, ist, dass sie nicht mehr so bereit sind zu akzeptieren, dass das, was da vorne unten irgendjemand erzählt, die Wahrheit ist und das, was jetzt unbedingt die Welt für sie ausmachen wird. Sondern sie haben dieses Bewusstsein von dieser unglaublichen Menge an Informationen und Wissen da draußen, im Internet, wo sie sich das alles dann nochmal anschauen können. Es schreibt auch fast niemand mehr mit.
Der Lehrer ist nicht mehr die einzige Autorität?
Ja, das ist auch etwas, wo viele schwer zu kiefeln haben. Die Lehrer? Und ich glaube auch, dass die Scheu, Fehler zu machen, abnimmt.
Was gut ist, oder?
Was ausgezeichnet ist. Ich finde das ganz großartig. Einfahren mit Schmack ist etwas ganz Wichtiges. Ich würde das zurückführen auf die Erfahrungen mit dem Computerspielen, wo einfahren oder etwas nicht schaffen, ein Lernprozess ist.
Da ist Game over und dann hat man aber wieder ein neues Leben und fängt einfach nochmal von vorne an, solange man durch alle Level durchgeht.
Ich würde den Game Research auch gerne als Learning by Dying bezeichnen. Warum hat Mario 3 Leben? Das ist eine ganz spannende Frage. Damit man lernen kann.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Wenn man jedes Mal wieder ganz an den Anfang zurückkäme, würde man das aufhören. Es gibt auch Spiele, die versagen entsetzlich deswegen. Aber wenn man dort, wo man stirbt, weitermachen kann und es noch einmal versuchen kann, noch einmal.
Habt ihr auch schon mal überlegt, hier so Hüpfkissen in die Flur aufzubauen?
Ja, so diese großen Würfel, wo man dann von unten dran hoppst und dann fliegen um die Goldmünzen raus.
Das wäre doch mal was. Wir haben auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Studenteninterface.
Vielleicht mache ich ganz kurz einen Detour. Wir machen ja hier Game Design seit ein paar Jahren. Wir sind jetzt schon, ich glaube, wir sind Inkubator für die dritte Firma jetzt. Es gibt drei Wiener Game Design-Firmen, die bei uns entstanden sind. Zwei von Studenten, einer von den Mitarbeitern, der gerade gegangen ist. Und hier eine ganze Reihe von außerordentlich interessanten Spielmangel. Enteerted Moves. Enteerted Moves dreht sich doch ein Spiel, ein Jump'n'Run, wo man die Welt in 90-Grad-Schritten dreht, anstatt überall raufhüppen zu müssen. Genau, man rennt dorthin und dann kippt man die Welt und rennt die Wand hinauf sozusagen. Das ist ein Puzzle-Platformer, könnte man sagen. Ein ganz, ganz großartiges Spiel mit einer einzigartigen Ästhetik, sind wir ganz stolz darauf, dass die von uns sind. Zombies and Sheep, ein iPhone-Game, ganz frisch jetzt, von einer anderen, von Studio Radularis, oder dieses Radio-Flare, das heißt vielleicht schon mit einem Musik-Game, ein ganz, ein...
Auf dem iPhone. Habe ich, glaube ich, sogar installiert. Aber ich komme wenig dazu. Ja, genau, weil Spiele sind ja tatsächlich, wie hast du gerade so schön gesagt, ein schöner Ideen-Inkubator eigentlich. Weil man dort, das hat sich ja schon eigentlich auch so mit den 80er Jahren schon abgezeichnet, da waren ja eigentlich die Spiele für viele Leute auch das eigentliche Interface. Die haben sich um die Kommandozeile wenig gekümmert, sondern für die lebte der Computer erst in dem Moment, wo man über diese zwei, drei Befehle, um das Spiel zu laden, hinweggekommen ist. Und dann ging es irgendwie los und dann hatte man Menüs und dann war das irgendwie grafisch und dann konnte man irgendwie F1 und F8 und so weiter und dann hatte das irgendwie seine Struktur. Jedes Spiel hatte eine andere Ästhetik, jedes Spiel hatte auch andere Elemente, die letzten Endes dort präsentiert werden mussten, weil es ja immer um was anderes ging. Und so war jedes Spiel auch immer wieder ein komplett neues Spielfeld im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes für ein neues User-Interface. Und ähnlich, denke ich, sieht man das auch im Web, auch so diese manchmal so unerträgliche Flashwelle. Ja, da kann man jetzt denken, darüber wie man will. Ich habe da auch so meine Zurückhaltung. Trotzdem muss man auch klar sehen, was sich dadurch im Bereich User-Interface an Ideen ausgelebt hat. Da ist auch viel gestorben, aber es sind natürlich auch Dinge übrig geblieben und es wurde auch schnell klar, wo andere Systeme dann sozusagen einen Mangel hatten. Dass sie zwar meinten, das bräuchte man nicht, aber es hat sich dann so gezeigt, dass man das eben dann doch haben will. Das konnte sich eben nur in diesen Experimentierfeldern überhaupt erstmal ausleben. Und ich denke, Spiele spielen eine große Rolle. Wenn du jetzt sagst, jetzt kommt sozusagen auch noch, dass das eigentliche Lernen des Menschen an sich wird dadurch auch noch beflügelt, dann ist das ja eine gute Paarung.
Man könnte das auf technologischer Sicht durchaus auch als Learning by Dying bezeichnen. Viele Dinge werden ausprobiert in Spielen. Spiele sind da wesentlich experimenteller unterwegs, was das angeht. Viele dieser Technologien, Interface-Ideen, Interaktionsformen sterben, aber wir lernen daraus enorm viel. Wenn man sich heutige Computer anschaut, dann ist ganz klar, dass die substanziell durch Spiele geformt sind. Die Tatsache, dass da so eine obszön-starke Grafikkarte drinsteckt, ist nur darauf zurückzuführen, dass so viel gespielt wird. Sogar in diesen dünnen Platten da ist ja Leistung drinnen, wo die Grafikkarte mehr kann als der Prozessor an reiner Rechenleistung. Und das geht eben schon zurück bis in diese 50er Jahre, wo die mit ihrem Technomodel Railroad Club da diese Star Wars programmieren. Und dann findet sich dieselbe Technologie in Sage, dem größten System der Zeit, das hier gebaut wurde. Also man sieht, die Innovationen passieren sehr oft in diesem Game-Bereich. 3D kommt nur aus dem Game-Bereich eigentlich. Alle Versuche 3D zu machen außerhalb vom Game-Bereich, würde ich heute einmal...
Spiel und Krieg?
Ja, natürlich auch. Architekturvisualisierung und alle diese Dinge ist natürlich schon sehr nett und so, aber die Anwendungen sind in Krieg und Spiel. Genau. Und das ist auch die Geschichte des Computers, Krieg und Spiel. Man könnte sogar noch einen Schritt zurückgehen und sehen, dass es diese Spielgeräte gab und diese mechanischen Vorzeige, Figuren, die geschrieben und gezeichnet haben, die man aufgezogen hat. Feinmechanische Wunderwerke, könnte man sagen. Die Ente vom Vaucassin, der eine künstliche Ente gebaut hat. Die konnte man füttern. Die hat das verdauert und hinten rausgeschissen. Mechanisch? Ja, die ist verschollen. Die gibt es nur als Nachbau. Darum heißt sie die verschollene Ente des Monsieur Vaucassin. Aber der schachspielende Türke.
Die Ente ist sozusagen so ein Frühzeit-Tamagotchi.
Ja, ich glaube, es ging eher um diesen Show-off. Ja, es starb nicht, wenn man sich die Ente erinnert. Man muss sich vorstellen, die Möglichkeiten an Home-Entertainment zu dieser Zeit waren begrenzt. Und wenn man sich da jemanden einladen konnte, der mit seinem Entenmaschine herumgereist ist, dann hat man die ganze Nachbarschaft eingeladen und gezeigt, wen man da tollen einlädt. Und dann hat er das vorgeführt. Das war schon sehr beeindruckend. Oder diese zeichnenden Kinder, die da, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der geheißen hat. Oder eben den Schachspiel in den Türken, vom Kempelen. Das war seine Türkenfigur mit seinem Schachbrett vor sich. Und der hat die Leute im Schach geschlagen. Eine Maschine, die Schach spielt und die anderen schlägt.
War aber keine, sondern war alles nur Fake.
Genau, ganz spannend. Gleichzeitig eine spannende Geschichte, darüber zu reflektieren, was ist das Bild von Technologie, was projizieren wir in diese Technologie hinein. Die Vorstellungen zu der Zeit waren, dass es möglich ist, ein mechanisches Gerät zu bauen, das denkt. Das war mit der aufkommenden Komplexität und das war eigentlich auch der Procassant, der wollte einen Mensch bauen. Er hat mit seiner Ente angefangen, also es war sicher vorher andere Dinge gebaut, aber da war die Ente ein Schritt. Der hat auch dieses Sprechgerät gebaut, das ist sicher schon mal wo gesehen, wo man mit so mehreren Hebeln so komische Dinge manipuliert und dann kommen so komische Geräusche raus, die klingen dann wie Mähmäh oder Bähmäh. Oder nicht die einfachen Worte, die gehen alle gut, und die schwierigen, da wird ein bisschen... Poststrukturalismus kriegt man das nicht hin.
In den ersten 12 Monaten noch halb stimuliert.
Ja, genau, aber das waren alles Versuche, den künstlichen Mensch zu bauen. Und die Technologie hat auch das Bild von Menschen geprägt, man hat sich den Mensch als eine fleischlich umgesetzte große Maschine vorgestellt. Da gibt es auch Darstellungen von einem Mensch als Industrieunternehmen, wo da drinnen so kleine Arbeiter das Essen in den Magen schaufeln und so.
Die Kultur hat das ja auch aufgenommen. Ich denke, das ist natürlich ein Metropolis.
Das ist heute nichts anderes. Was projizieren wir in den Maschinen? Was trauen wir ihnen zu? Und auf der anderen Seite, wie definieren wir uns selber? Da sind wir jetzt ein bisschen darüber hinweg, diese Vorstellung, dass unser Gehirn ein Computer ist.
Aber man versucht sich schon auch ein bisschen in der Maschine immer selber zu finden.
Richtig, genau.
Es gibt ja noch andere schöne kulturelle Vorlagen. Blade Runner, diese Idee, diese Replikanten, Nexus 6, die Maschinen mit eingebauten Sicherheitssystemen, die nach vier Jahren sterben, die dann in so eine eigene Welt eintauchen und sich fragen, was bin ich eigentlich, wenn ich sterbe? Warum darf ich nicht leben? Warum bin ich nicht genauso? Was hast du, Battlestar Galactica? Das ist ähnlich groß in der Shell.
Aber auch diese Frage, was machen Maschinen, wenn sie bewusst werden? Die ja eigentlich Battlestar Galactica bestimmt. Die Frage ist, was passiert mit den Maschinen, wenn sie bewusst werden? Die Annahme dort ist, als erstes metzeln sie uns alle nieder, weil wir sich Schweine gegenüber ihnen warnen. Und jetzt gibt es diese komischen, jetzt reden sie ja schon von dieser Entwicklung autonomer Kampfthronen. Und jetzt gab es vor ein paar Wochen die ersten warnenden Stimmen von AI-Forschern, die gesagt haben, macht das nicht, bitte ersparen wir uns das. Wir wissen, Software fehlt Funktionen, wir wissen, Software ist nie perfekt, da kann man eindringen. Also wir sollten das nicht tun. Und das sind ganz spannende Fragen, die plötzlich kommen, aber die stecken im Kern von uns. Wir fragen uns immer, was wir sind. Und auf der anderen Seite, wie wir uns in der Technologie replizieren können.
Das ist natürlich auch wieder eine kulturelle Frage, die in anderen Ländern ja anders aussieht. Also diese Angst vor dem übermenschlichen Frankenstein-Monster ist ja ein ganz deutliches Ding der westlichen Welt. Man hat immer Angst, das ist immer so die Maschine-Terminator, die Maschinen übernehmen und so weiter. Wenn man zum Beispiel nach Japan schaut, hat man ein ganz anderes Bild. Da ist der Helfer des Menschen. Es wird die ganze Zeit nur darüber geredet, wie man eine Maschine bauen kann, die älteren Menschen durch den Tag bringt und so weiter. Der Assistent und der Butler bringt den Tee vorbei und macht ordentlich Männchen und verbeugt sich natürlich auch, wie sich das gehört. Es ist interessant, was der Mensch da hinein projiziert, was er letztendlich auch möchte.
Ich glaube, da stecken zwei grundlegende Fragen drin, wenn man ganz nach unten taucht. Auf der einen Seite immer die Frage, was sind wir denn selber? Über welche Modelle und Metaphern können wir verstehen, warum wir sind und wie wir sind? Zur Zeit mechanischer Maschinen haben wir uns als eine sehr komplexe, fleischlich gewordene mechanische Maschine verstanden, metaphorisch, und haben versucht, das so zu erklären. Und umgekehrt dann das daraus Gelernte wieder zu bauen. Das sind diese zwei Dinge, die wir immer wieder finden.
Hat aber eigentlich nicht funktioniert.
Bis jetzt hat das noch nicht funktioniert. Nein, nicht einmal annähernd. Und deswegen war aber der Schachspielende Türke so ein Schlager, weil man wollte das ja glauben. Und deswegen hat es funktioniert. Und der Kempeler hat das immer her gezeigt. Und ich habe gesagt, nein Schatz, Klappe auf, da sitzt jemand drinnen, jetzt könnt ihr euch darüber den Kopf zerbrechen, wie der sieht, was da oben auf dem Schachbrett passiert.
Genau, es gibt noch genug Rätsel. Gehen wir vielleicht mal wieder zurück zu den konkreten Computermaschinen und der durchaus fleisch gewordenen Vision des digitalen Assistenten. Ich denke, das ist die Vision, die sich eigentlich auch erfüllt hat und auch täglich aufs Neue immer wieder sich verstärkt und verbessert wird. Wir waren ja vorhin stehen geblieben bei Alan Kay so als einen der Visionäre, wie man mit Computern interagieren kann. Er war ja auch eine Zeit lang bei Apple und hat dort mit anderen User-Interfaces gebaut. Heute ist er immer noch umtriebig und auch diese Idee mit dem grafischen Programmieren ist in so Projekten wie Squeaks und Smalltalk-basiertes System. Da steckt er ja auch immer noch ein Stück weit dahinter. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie sein konkretes Involvement jetzt da gerade aussieht. Wird sicherlich auch langsam älter. Aber es gab ja auch noch ein paar andere Pioniere, die so einen... Oder fällt ihr zu Alan Kay jetzt spezifisch noch was ein?
Ansonsten würde mir vor allem dieser Herr Engelbart noch ein Zitat vom Alan Kay vorlesen, weil mich das immer wieder verblüfft, wie sehr er 1968 Notebooks von 40 Jahre später beschreibt.
Das heißt diese Dynabook-Schichte nochmal?
Genau, er beschreibt das Dynabook als ein Gerät mit considerable local storage.
Also viel Speicher.
Genau, most computing locally. Das meiste wird lokal berechnet. Will spend a large percentage of its time hooked to various large global information utilities. Das ist genau das, was wir heute machen.
Internet.
Which permit communication with others of ideas, working models, as well as the daily chit chat, Twitter, that organizations need in order to function. Das ist so eine präzise Beschreibung eines Notebooks.
Das war von wann?
1968. Und das finde ich schon beeindruckend. Dass er da...
41 Jahre her.
Genau, dass er da so 30 Jahre in die Zukunft projiziert Technologien und deren Arbeitsweisen beschreibt.
Dass deiner Book von damals ist quasi der Laptop heute.
Könnte man... ja und nein. Als Technologie und als Kompaktheit der Technologie auf alle Fälle, als die Art und Weise, wie er sich vorgestellt hat, dass es für Kinder ist, als ein Gerät des Lernens und der Entwicklung von Literacy in den Informationskommunikationen, eigentlich noch nicht. Das ist seine Geschichte, die am ehesten noch versucht wurde mit diesem OLPC. Die haben das ja versucht. Die haben sich da ganz explizit an diesen Visionen vom Dynabook orientiert mit diesem Interface vom OLPC. Ich glaube, sie sind gescheitert, aber sie haben es zumindest versucht. Das ist schon nochmal toll.
Ja, ich denke, es wird nicht der letzte Versuch geblieben sein. Wir sehen ja, wie die Wirkung auf Kinder ist und mit welchem geringen Alter Kinder heute schon was mit dem Computer anfangen können, weil sie eben auch früh begreifen.
Und was für eine Geschwindigkeit die lernen. Sehr spooky. Die generalisieren das sofort, die verstehen das alles. Meine sind fünf und sieben und ich bin jedes Mal wieder baff. Inzwischen dürfen sie nicht mehr zum Computer, wenn ich nicht da bin, weil sie zu viel können.
Ganz wichtig. Die großen Visionen, das ist immer das eine. Eine andere Sache ist auch, was hat sich konkret manifestiert. Vieles von dem, was Ellen K gemacht hat. Er hat ja auch selber dazu beigetragen mit seiner Arbeit am Mac, dass es sich konkret manifestiert hat. Ich denke, Engelbart ist auch noch eine ganz wichtige Person. Es gibt da ja auch dieses großartige Video. Ich habe es auch schon mal bei ChaosTV online gestellt. Die Mutter aller Demos. Ich weiß nicht, wann das Video diesen Namen erhalten hatte. Aber wann war das nochmal?
9. Dezember 1968.
Also auch das gleiche Jahr.
Das war schon sehr fortgeschritten, was er da gezeigt hat. Da stecken Jahre und Jahre an Experimentieren und Forschern drinnen. Ich habe Dagers Engelbart vor vielen Jahren. Von ihm ist die Maus. Das ist ja der Kern, den man mit Dagers Engelbart verbindet. Darum heißt er auch Mighty Maus. Das ist sein Spitzname. Und die gleichnamige Apple Maus hat ihn um Erlaubnis gefragt. Diesen Namen verwenden zu dürfen. Es war eine Homage an ihn. Wir nennen diese Maus Mighty Maus, um Dagers Engelbart zu würdigen als den Erfinder der Maus. Aber viele andere Dinge auch. Aus seiner Research Group kommt also die Anwendung der Schreibmaschinentastatur für den Computer, der Rasterbildschirm, das Chord-Keyboard, eine Tastatur, wo man fünf Tasten hat, die man gleichzeitig drückt zum Teil.
Die kommt auch in dieser Demo vor, ne?
Ja, genau. Und auf die ist er unendlich gestanden.
Hat sich aber nicht so durchgesetzt.
Nicht wahnsinnig, nein. Ich hab ihn einmal gesehen vor 15 Jahren auf einer Konferenz, vielleicht schon 20, ist ja so peinlich, wie schnell man alt wird, so eine Keynote zu geben und er hat damals noch immer diese Chord-Tastatur her gezeigt und hat damit gearbeitet. Es war beeindruckend, wie schnell er damit arbeitet. Aber man muss eigentlich Klavier spielen können, damit man die Koordination in den Fingern hat, um jede beliebige Kombination von Tasten prompt drücken zu können. Fullscreen editieren, das gemeinsame Arbeiten an einem Text, gerade einmal jetzt, seit ein paar Jahren, haben wir das wieder, das war es in seinem System, das war das drinnen. Links waren drinnen, hochauflösende Bildschirme, Einbindung von Medien, Fenstern, Windowing, Messaging, also viele Dinge, die wir heute für selbstverständlich nehmen, kommen aus dieser Research Group, die er da geleitet hat, die hieß Research Center for Augmenting Human Intellect.
Also auch hier so die Vision des Gedankenverstärkers ganz klar vorne. Aber was sich wirklich manifestiert hat, ist im Prinzip ja diese Maus und Fenster-Geschichte, das denke ich mal, ist so das größte Vermächtnis. Also es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die ganzen anderen Konzepte jetzt auch allgegenwärtig wären, hast du ja eben schon gesagt, so kollaboratives Editieren, Aufkommen des Internets, jetzt gibt es einfach die Infrastruktur, dafür sorgt das eben genug Leute, das dann auch wirklich gleichzeitig tun wollen und auch tun können. Aber wenn man jetzt sich anschaut, wie die Computer sich wirklich entwickelt haben und vor allem, wie die Computer dann ihren Weg gefunden haben in den Mainstream, kann man glaube ich schon sagen, mit der Geburt der fensterbasierten Oberfläche, mit der Maus und vielleicht ein Stück weit auch mit dieser Schreibtisch-Metapher, wobei die finde ich schon ein bisschen fragwürdig, ist eigentlich der Durchbruch gelungen. Ich weiß bloß nicht, lag es daran oder wäre der Durchbruch ohnehin gekommen? Also welchen Beitrag, denkst du, haben so diese User Interfaces geleistet?
Ich glaube, dass es schwer ist, von einem Durchbruch zu sprechen. Denn wenn man sich die verschiedenen Systeme der Reihe nach anordnet und anschaut, dann versteht man wie viel Gepäck von alten Gedankengut sozusagen in jedem noch drinnen steckt und wie das erst langsam verloren geht. Wie das erst langsam rausgenommen wird aus diesem Rucksack. Gerade wenn man sich diese Mother of All Demos anschaut, der Umgang mit Text, da braucht man sich nur die ersten zehn Minuten anschauen, der Umgang mit Text ist unglaublich programmatisch. Die Art und Weise, wie mit Text umgegangen wird und wie die Maus funktioniert, ist noch so anders, wie das heute ist.
Inwiefern anders?
Mit der Maus fährt man nur hin und zeigt, und dann werden Kommandos ausgelöst. Also zum Beispiel fahre ich da hin und dann macht der Klacker die Klack auf seiner Chorddassatur, das heißt jetzt von hier, dann fährt er dorthin und dann sagt er bis hier, dann fährt er woanders hin und sagt jetzt nach hier. Und das ist ganz anders, wie es heute funktioniert. Nämlich nicht unbedingt in der Umsetzung, sondern in der Denke, die oben drüber steckt. Das ist nicht Copy and Paste, sondern das ist, ich sage jetzt von hier und bis hier, möchte ich irgendwas später mal damit machen, was ich jetzt noch nicht sage. Dann gehe ich irgendwo anders hin.
Gut, das ist aber die Selektion, oder?
Ja, aber es ist keine Selektion, weil wir sehen sie nicht. Und sie wird auch nicht mit, das Schöne an der Art und Weise, wie die Maus heute funktioniert, ist, dass sie ein haptisch überzeugendes Gerät ist. Ich gehe hin und wenn ich diese Maus Taste drücke, ist meine Hand in Anspannung. Und wenn ich jetzt ein, sagen wir, ich dokumentiere, ich kopiere ein Dokument von einer Platte auf eine andere. Dann nehme ich dieses Dokument und weil ich die Hand anspanne, wird die Maus fast zu diesem Dokument, das ich mit der Maus auf die andere Platte ziehe und dort fallen lasse. Und ich lasse es dort aus. Oder ich ziehe sogar den Mistkübel. Ich lasse es dort aus. Und diese wirklich überzeugende Art der Verwendung der Maus als eine Metapher für die Dinge, die ich da drin manipuliere, die entsteht erst mit Drag'n'Drop, die entsteht erst mit vielen anderen Konzepten, die dazukommen. Und das ist etwas, was mit diesem System von Drangreichs Egelbad noch überhaupt nicht zu beobachten ist, nicht einmal ansatzweise. Und das ist auch im Xerox Star nicht drinnen. Es gibt eine schöne Demo vom Xerox Star, findet man auf Digibaden, glaube ich, heißt die Seite. Und da wird der Xerox Star vorgeführt. Und wenn man jetzt ein bisschen ein Verständnis hat für die Geschichte, dann sieht man plötzlich ein System, wo Kommandos über so beschriftete Tasten ausgelöst wird. Da gibt es eine Ando-Taste.
Welches System heißt das?
Der Xerox Star. Das war so das große Durchbruchsystem. Also wird oft als solches gezeigt.
Also sozusagen das Ding, wo das erste Mal Fenster basierte Oberflieger sichtbar waren, wo auch die Maus im Prinzip schon konzeptionell drin verankert waren.
Genau. Aber noch immer stärker gedanklich oder sagen wir so als ein Mittelwert, zwischen dem, wie wir die Maus heute verwenden und dem, wie Douglas Engelbert sie verwendet hat. Dragon Drop gibt es halt nicht. Man fährt mit der Maus zu einem Icon, dann drückt man die Move-Taste. Dafür gab es eine eigene Taste auf der Tastatur. Dann hat man die Maus irgendwo anders hin bewegt und dann hat man die, weiß ich nicht, Drop-Taste oder man hat geklickt oder was auch immer. Das fühlt sich ganz anders an, wenn man es anschaut, als wir heute damit arbeiten.
Schon ein bisschen mehr wie dieser Lichtgriffel von dem Self-System.
Genau, ein bisschen noch wie dieser Lichtgriffel. Die Maus wird zu den Dingen, die ich manipuliere, steckt da noch gar nicht drinnen. Und mit den Fenstern genauso. Ich fahre zu dem Fenster, da habe ich dieselbe Move-Taste. Das ist Programmierer-Denken, so orthogonales Denken. Jeder Command gilt auch für jedes Objekt. Dass sich normalen Menschen meistens verschließt. Diese Generalisierung schaffen viele nicht. Dass sie sagen, da kann ich dieselbe Move-Taste verwenden. Ich probiere das mal oder so. Das ist etwas, was der Jeff Reskin dann noch bringt. Der Jeff Reskin ist der, der Dragon Drop macht. Damit ist der Jeff Reskin ein ganz großer für die Maus. Der gern so ein bisschen auf den Tisch gekehrt wird. Aber der Jeff Reskin ist der mit Dragon. Der Jeff Reskin ist der, der Steve Jobs und seine ganze Crew nach Xerox Park zehrt. Sagt, schaut euch das an.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Genau. Dann zahlen sie diese Aktienoptionen. Das war ja ein teurer Event, den sie da gemacht haben. Die haben einem Werk von Aktienoptionen, ich glaube eine Million Dollar in Optionen, an Xerox gezahlt, damit sie sich das anschauen dürfen.
Wirklich?
Und das ist auch ein bisschen so, die Entkräftung ist ja auch nur abgeschaut. Das ist bezahlt. Sie haben sich das angeschaut, sie haben es bezahlt und dann durften sie es auch machen. Und die nehmen das und die nehmen gleich ein paar Leute mit von dort, die dort sitzen und eingeklemmt sind an diesem Rucksack, von dem ich vorhin gesprochen habe, mit diesen alten Ideen, die da auch mitmüssen, und nehmen die mit und gehen und machen was ganz anderes. Und das ist ein weiterer Schritt, ist auch nur ein Schritt. Es wird also ein kleiner Schritt. Und dann stehen wir jetzt bei der Art und der erste Mecke auch noch nicht. Da gab es ganz viele Dinge, die noch nicht so richtig...
Kleine Schritte, aber waren auch schon große Schritte für die Menschheit jetzt dabei?
Ja, natürlich. Wenn man das als 7-Meilen-Stiefel-Schritt versteht, dann ist das ganz erstaunlich. Denn was dabei quasi implizit entstanden ist, ist, dass man sich verabschiedet hat von der Hardware, die steuert. Der Mac hatte keine Taste mehr, die beschriftet war, als eine besondere Funktionstaste. Da gab es die Return-Taste am ersten noch und die Tab. Das war eigentlich nur eine Schreibmaschine. Es gab keine Funktionstasten, keine Copy- und keine Help-Taste, keine Left- und Right-Taste. Der Xerox Star hatte eine Reihe von Tasten zur Textformatierung. Bold, Italic, Fett. Es ist schon nicht dumm zu sagen, das machen wir die meiste Zeit, also machen wir dafür Tasten.
In gewisser Hinsicht auch einfacher zu erlernen, weil das natürlich nicht wahr ist.
Gleichzeitig aber auch das alte Paradigma. Diese Steuerungstasten, die sich dann noch halten, die sind dann weg. Die Maus wird zu diesem Interaktionsdevice, zu dem Zentralen, in einem anderen Paradigma der Interaktion, wo der Computer komplett passiv wird plötzlich. Auch nicht plötzlich, auch in diesen ganzen Schritten. Und nur noch das machen soll, was ich ihm anschaffe. Das nennt man im Allgemeinen diese direkte Manipulation. Das hat der Ben Schneiderman dann als solches beschrieben. Und das wird zu dem großen Interaktionsdesign-Paradigma ab den 80er Jahren. Dass der Computer von sich aus nichts tut. Dass er passiv dasitzt und wartet, dass er ein visuelles Funktionsangebot hat und dass alles, was ich tue, auch ein unmittelbares Feedback erzeugt. Das sind so die drei großen Eckpfeiler der direkten Manipulation. Das war vorher nicht so. Der Computer ist hoch gestartet und links unten ist ein Cursor geblinkt. Oder links oben. Leerer Bildschirm, ich weiß nicht, was ich tun kann. Ich tippe irgendeinen Command ein, ich drücke Return und dann passiert erst einmal gar nichts. Weil der Computer denkt jetzt. Manche von den netteren Utilities haben geschrieben, ich denke, du wartest oder I think you wait oder Punkte hingezeichnet, was auch immer. Aber eigentlich ist nichts passiert. Und dann war das Ergebnis da. Und dann habe ich was anderes gemacht. Und dann stimmt das oben vielleicht gar nicht mehr. Ich habe LS, Directory Listing, dann lösche ich 2-3 Files und das Listing, das oben steht, stimmt eigentlich nicht mehr. Und das ist an, das ist eine direkte Manipulation. Alles, was ich sehe, stimmt. Es ist eine Repräsentation des internen Zustandes.
Aber man verliert auch die Geschichte.
Man verliert natürlich die Geschichte. Man kann jetzt darüber nachdenken, wie man sie wieder bekommen könnte. Aber prinzipiell verliert man sie.
Die Kommando-Zeile ist ja sehr hartnäckig. Man könnte ja glauben, okay, now that we have a mouse and Windows, weg damit und so. In gewisser Hinsicht in der populären Anwendung ist das ja auch so. Wenn man heutzutage jemanden Macintosh vor die Nase stellt, der arbeitet da irgendwie ein halbes Jahr mit, der hat keine Ahnung, dass da irgendwo in den Tiefen noch ein Terminal schrimmert, wo man so Sachen eingeben kann. Dann kennst du den Effekt sicherlich, wenn man dann irgendwann mal bei einem Problem aushelfen soll. Und dann als erstes diese Fensterwelt beiseiteräumt, weil die einfach im Weg ist, um sich das Detail anzuschauen. Dann tippt man ein paar magische Kommandos ein und die Leute staunen, als hätte man gerade die Maschine geöffnet und so eine blau leuchtende Kugel wäre nach oben gestiegen. Dabei ist das ja eigentlich normal.
Ich finde, das sollten sie ja mal einbauen. Das wäre für uns sehr hilfreich.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Kugel anfassen. Ja, trotzdem. Was ich interessant finde, ist, die Manuteile wird nicht weggehen. Das ist, was ich glaube, für eine bestimmte Zielgruppe. Weil sie eben natürlich eine ganz andere Interaktion möglich macht. Dass man wirklich auf Eye-Level wieder kommt. Man schaut der Maschine mehr oder weniger direkt ins Gesicht und setzt sich auf eine andere Art und Weise damit auseinander.
Im Gegenteil, sie kommt sogar wieder im Morgenmantel sozusagen. Also Quicksilver oder Spotlight sind eigentlich eine Commandline.
Also diese kurzen Abkürzungstools.
Genau, Quicksilver, ich mache Klack-die-klack, dann kommt irgendein Eingabefeld. Und dann beginne ich den Namen meiner Applikation zu schreiben und wenn ich am Feedback sehe, dass ich es ausreichend lang geschrieben habe, starte ich es mit der Return-Tasche. Das selbe geht mit Spotlight, dasselbe geht am iPhone mit dieser Suchfunktion. Du gehst bei 3.0 auf diese Suchseite und dann tippst du eigentlich. Das ist eigentlich eine Command-Line. Eine sehr kleine Command-Line im Morgenmantel, aber es ist eine Command-Line. Und das ist eine Vision, die eigentlich auch genauso alt ist, dass du diese Direktmanipulationsinterfaces durchaus damit verheiraten kannst. Der Jeff Reskin hat dieses Commands-everywhere-Konzept entwickelt. Der war ja schon lange bei Apple, den haben sie ja ziemlich mies da hinaus geäkelt. Und dann hat er dieses Commands-everywhere. Und Commands-everywhere ist eigentlich Quicksilver. Wenn man Quicksilver so richtig nützt, dann kann man ja damit am Web suchen, dann kann man damit in seinen Kontakten suchen und alles mögliche aus dem Computer rausholen. Und man muss nicht zum Terminal gehen, sondern das Terminal kommt quasi zu mir. Ich habe zwar nur diese eine Zeile, aber das genügt ja für den ersten Teil.
Es ist sozusagen eine Melange aus dem grafischen User-Interface.
Und da gibt es ein Buch von Jeff Reskin, das steht hier irgendwo rum, wo er ein ganzes Interface basierend rund um dieses Commands Everywhere-Konzept beschreibt. Das zerbricht dann zwar irgendwann an seiner, ich sage mal, an seiner Kohärenz und an dem Willen, es wirklich genauso zu machen und so. Alles muss sich diesem Prinzip jetzt unterordnen. Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es gut funktionieren würde. Aber es kommt zu uns. Und das finde ich ganz faszinierend. Es gibt ein paar andere Aspekte, wo das auch so ist. Google ist eigentlich auch eine Command Line geworden. Wenn ich in Google suche, dann kann ich ja genug Modifier dazuschreiben, um daraus verschiedene sinnvolle oder zum Teil auch gefährliche Queries zu machen.
Bevor wir zum unvermeidlichen Thema Web kommen, müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal da ein bisschen in die Zeit blicken. Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen von Engelbart über Xerox zum Mac gekommen und damit quasi zu dieser Geburtsstunde Fenster basierte Systeme. Dann kann man ja sagen, zumindest im Mainstream hat sich das jetzt erstmal verankert.
Da gab es dann zig Systeme von kleinen Herstellern, die versucht haben, das genauso zu machen. Da gab es sich von Amiga und Atari und Geos gab es auf dem C4 und so. Da gab es zig solche kleinen...
Aber es war immer wieder dasselbe. Im Prinzip haben sie eigentlich nur zwei Systeme langfristig wirklich durchgesetzt, ist ja klar, der Mac und Windows. Wie siehst du, das ist so die unvermeidliche Frage, wie siehst du jetzt diese beiden populären Systeme nebeneinander? Ist das jetzt eigentlich nur noch Ballast, was die mit sich führen, oder siehst du da schon auch eine gewisse Reife und Effizienz in der Art und Weise, wie sich die Computer heutzutage dem Benutzer präsentieren, oder ist so die Simplicität des Webbs das neue Modell? Okay, ich hätte das letztendlich gleich weglassen sollen. Also bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal bei Mac und bei Windows. Wie kommt dir das so persönlich vor? Also was freut euch auf dich zu holen?
Also ich bin jetzt erstmal ein Mac-User, seit 84. Seit 84, du bist verloren. Ich hab die schlimmsten Zeiten mit durchgemacht und eisern durchgehalten. Und ich glaube, man kann ein paar Dinge dazu sagen. Zum einen, die Geschichten haben in den letzten Jahren so viel an Komplexität dazu gewonnen, dass es verständlich ist, dass jeder auf seine Welt steht. Wenn du ein paar Jahre in der einen Welt verbracht hast und dort einigermaßen zufrieden bist, dann kann ich das nachvollziehen und kann sagen, weil du so viele Kompetenzen aufgebaut hast und du wirst dir im Grunde, wenn du jetzt Plattform wechselst, egal in welche Richtung, wirst du ja eigentlich gedemütigt und gezwungen, dich einem anderen Paradigma unterzuordnen. Jetzt sage ich, das Paradigma unter Windows ist vielleicht stärker die Corporate Control. Da gibt es mehr so dieses, die haben eher so den Markt in den Firmen im Kopf immer und die Anforderungen dessen. Und da gibt es ein paar Strukturen, die sich eher dem anpassen. Und die hier, die Macs, die haben eher so diesen, auf der einen Seite diese Simplifizierung aller Dinge, die mich sehr anspricht, weil ich selber so gestalte. Und auf der anderen Seite halt so ein bisschen dieses, was kümmert dich, wenn das jetzt nicht mehr geht. Was ein bisschen manchmal ganz schön enervierend sein kann.
Du meinst, wenn dieses Feature nicht mehr angeboten wird?
Ja, wenn das viel eingespart wird. Genau, weil es zu, weil es übersimplifiziert wurde. Man entdeckt, dass es immer wieder zurückkommt, irgendwo anders. Und man wird oft genug verblüfft, um dafür entschädigt zu werden. Aber trotzdem ist das schon eine andere Form von Corporate-Control. Das ist nicht der Client Corporate, der kontrolliert, sondern das ist die Mothership, die kontrolliert. Diese Kontrolle kann manchmal schon sehr nervend sein, aber sie kann auch sehr heilsam sein. Man beobachtet das sehr gut bei Shareware. Die Shareware-Szene, glaube ich, ist unter Windows und Mac sehr verschieden. Es gibt unglaublich viele brillante kleine Software auf Mac von irgendwelchen Developern gemacht, die wunderschön zum anschauen ist und die auch gut funktioniert für die kleinen Funktionen. Unter Windows gibt es diese Taschenmessern mit den 58 Klingen, die man fast nicht mehr bequem halten kann, aber dafür hat man immer alles dabei. Ich glaube, das sind so die zwei Welken, die entstanden sind, die sind nicht zufällig entstanden. Und ich bin ganz zufrieden in der einen Welt, auch wenn man sich immer wieder mal auf den Zeh getreten fühlt.
Aber das ist jetzt so ein bisschen deine persönliche Perspektive. Wenn das so ein bisschen wissenschaftlicher angesehen wäre, ihr werdet euch ja sicherlich auch mal Windows als solches und den Mac als solches, sozusagen die User-Interfaces als solches angeschaut haben. Was sind denn so die entscheidenden Gewinner und Verlierer-Elemente in diesen User- Interfaces in der Art und Weise, wie du sagst, du fühlst dich auf den C getreten, wie sehr, war er schon mal blau, wodurch, was missfällt dir generell, oder sind diese Systeme eigentlich so ähnlich, dass es eigentlich wirklich nur noch Geschmacksfragen gibt?
Nein, nein, es ist nicht. Wenn ich dann unsere Studenten sehe, Studentinnen und Studenten, wenn sie sich da hier bei uns an den großen Screen hängen, um ihre Präsentationen zu machen oder ihre Entwürfe zu zeigen, dann denke ich mir immer wieder, meine Güte, wie könnt ihr euch das gefallen lassen? Es ist ja so entsetzlich bei euch da drüben. Manchmal ist es ja wirklich schrecklich, wenn man dann sieht, mit was für Software sie arbeiten und wie sloppy die Bildschirm-Updates sind und wie dieses Herumziehen von Dingen hinten nach hinkt. Es ist schwer jetzt einzelne Dinge festzumachen.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht so sehr auf Stabilität oder wie gut das programmiert ist, sondern eher mehr auf die Konzepte als solche hinaus. Wenn wir jetzt mal ein paar offensichtliche Unterschiede nehmen. Der Mac hat seine Menüzeile oben, die ist immer da, es gibt immer genau eine. Bei Windows ist es anders, da sind die in Fenstern, sind immer irgendwo anders und man hat aber dann auch mehrere im Blick. Gibt es da einen qualitativen Unterschied oder ist das eigentlich egal?
Wenn man jetzt Studien dazu anschaut, weil du sagst wissenschaftliche Betrachtung, dann kann man natürlich sofort sagen, dass das Modell der Menüzeile auf dem Bildschirm-Oberrand einen enormen Vorteil hat. Sie ist nämlich unendlich groß. Ich kann das jetzt im Sinne des Fitts Law, der so ein Rechenmodell zur Verfügung stellt, wie schnell man an etwas herankommt, dass man anklicken will.
Also Fitts Law sagt, Fitt ist wer?
Das ist so ein Forscher aus den, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall sein Law besagt, das was?
Das ist ein mathematischer Zusammenhang zwischen der Größe dessen, was ich anklicken will, der Entfernung, wie weit es weg ist, und ein paar anderen Faktoren, die so eine Rolle spielen, wenn ich da mit der Maus hinfahren will. Und nachdem die Menüleiste am Bildschirm-Oberrand so groß ist, wie ich mit der Maus nur hinauffahren kann, wird sie quasi unendlich groß im Sinne von Fitts Law und ist nicht zu verfehlen.
Weil man so dagegen stößt?
Weil man einfach dagegen knallt. Und das zum Windows-Menü-Leisten genau nicht. Da muss ich sehr genau hin, zielen und hinfahren. Das führt halt dann dazu, dass Windows-User viel mehr auf Tastaturkürzel zurückgreifen, was auch besser geht, weil normalerweise Windows-Applikationen schon vorausblickend mehr Tastaturkürzel zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das wiederum führt dazu, dass ich die Anwendung anders verwende. Also von dem her kann man viel darüber reden, was jetzt der abstrakte Vorteil ist. Im Endeffekt ist es eine Frage der Qualifikation und der Wünsche, der Art und Weise, damit umzugehen. Ich sehe, wenn ich jetzt vom User-Interface-Design weggehe, dann sehe ich andere Dinge, warum ich nicht in Windows sein möchte. Diese Tatsache, dass zwischen Administrator und Route nicht unterschieden wird. Das ist ein ganz grosses Manko im Sicherheitskonzept von Windows. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum das so eine beliebte Plattform ist, um sie zu hacken. Aber das sind andere Dinge.
Das sind andere Sachen. Die brauchen wir uns jetzt erstmal nicht zu interessieren. Ich wollte dich jetzt noch auf diese Frage des User-Interactions, aber große Unterschiede siehst du auch nicht mehr. Also eigentlich haben sich die Plattformen angenähert. Die Frage ist, ist das jetzt ein Dead-End? Ist dieses Fenster-Maus-Schreibtisch-Modell, kommt das irgendwie ans Ende?
Ich glaube, dass gerade in den letzten Jahren einiges an Bewegung hineingekommen ist. Wodurch? Zum einen durch diese computerübergreifende oder Desktop-Search, sagt man jetzt, Spotlight oder wie heißt das, Windows Search? Heißt es Windows Search? Oder Google Search?
Ich bin ja leider auch da.
Also diese Dinge, die man da so drauf pappt, die den ganzen Computer indizieren und wo man das alles findet. Und das ist ein wesentlich anderes Paradigma, das da gekommen ist. Ich muss mich nicht mehr erinnern, nur ich etwas hingegeben habe. Und das führt ultimativ dazu, dass mir, dass ich entlastet werde. Ich bin nicht mehr der Hausmeister meiner Dateien und ich muss immer mit dem Besen gehen und nachher aufputzen und zusammenräumen. Sondern ich werde sie schon finden. Das ist so irgendwie das Paradigma, das dazu hineingekommen ist.
Könnte das auch das Ende des hierarchischen Verzeichnisbaums sein?
Könnte.
Weil ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Leute damit sowieso nicht so gut umgehen können.
Ja, könnte, natürlich. Also Mail ist bei mir nicht mehr hierarchisch. Ich sortiere Mails nicht mehr. Meine Mail-Applikation sucht so schnell, dass Mails bei mir in der Inbox wohnen, aus. Oder im Mistkübel.
Aber da musst du ja immer alles suchen.
Ja, egal. Es dauert trotzdem nur ein, zwei Sekunden. Vollkommen egal.
Aber man muss auch immer wieder was eintippen.
Ja, aber...
Beziehungsweise du meinst, man macht keine Ordner mehr, sondern man macht so vordefinierte Suchanfragen oder was?
Nein, gar keine. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich gehe suchen. Wenn ich etwas finden will, dann gehe ich suchen, aus. Ich sortiere nicht nach Projekten oder nach Kommunikationspartnern oder nach privat und beruflich oder was auch immer. Ich habe einen Inbox aus. Und bei Mail ist genau das passiert. Ich habe meine hierarchische Organisation, die sehr elaboriert war, mehrstufige Folder, Strukturen, alles aufgegeben und ich suche. Und bei Dokumenten komme ich manchmal das Gefühl, ich komme auch schon in die Nähe. Also es gibt so Drop-Orte, wo ich Dinge hineinwerfe und ich werde sie schon wieder finden. In anderen Plätzen bin ich wieder sehr strukturiert und organisiert.
Aber das bedeutet ja auch, dass man ganz andere Wege finden muss, selber seine Daten zu kategorisieren, damit man sich später auch unterscheiden kann.
Genau, es gibt Dinge, die fügen sich diesem Desktop-Search-Paradigma mehr als andere. Bilder nicht, Bilder sind elend. Die Bilder kann man nicht suchen. Bilder muss man taggen oder Gesichtserkennung machen oder was auch immer, damit man sie suchen kann. Das geht dann nicht so. Aber Texte und PDFs und übliche Dokumente, die wird man schon wieder finden.
Und von der Suche abgesehen?
So Dinge wie Exposé oder das Aufblättern der verschiedenen Fenster, das es in Vista ja auch gibt.
Also, dass man eine Übersicht in die Fenster bekommt und eine dreidimensionale quasi mit einlädt.
Wo ich damals, wie ich die Demo gesehen habe, gemerkt habe, wie mein Gehirn beginnt, sich umzuorganisieren, weil ich jetzt so arbeiten kann. Das ist ganz faszinierend.
Ich verwende es fast nicht. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Ich weiß nicht warum, ist gut. Na, ich verwende es sehr viel.
Also es ist keine Ahnung. Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob ich so mit diesem Fenster-Ding und dieser Unterscheidung in Applikationen so glücklich bin. Gerade was du eben sagst über Mail. Ich habe gar keine Ordner mehr. Es gibt gar keine Kistchen, in denen das drin ist. Das ist dann auch schon immer so, wenn ich... Gut, da ist die Suche in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon wieder eine Hilfe. Man kommt einfach weg ein bisschen von diesem Programme-Konzept. Ich habe eine Rechnung geschrieben, ich weiß dann schon gar nicht mehr in welchem Programm eigentlich. Habe ich das jetzt irgendwie aus einer Spreadsheet-Anwendung heraus oder so einer Textverarbeitung? War das jetzt irgendwie doch in meiner Desktop-Database, die das irgendwie automatisch rauszieht? Es geht irgendwie verloren.
Es gab ja auch verschiedene Ansätze, wenn man jetzt zurückblickt, die versucht haben, das anders zu sehen. Livestreams war ein Versuch, einen ganz anderen Zugang zu der Menge an Daten, die man so erzeugt. Ich glaube, David Gelernta hat der geheißen. Der hat das dann nur extrem patentiert und diese Patente eingefordert, sodass es quasi nur von ihm autorisierte Umsetzungen gab, obwohl ich nicht glaube, dass das der Scheitereinsgrund war. Aber im Wesentlichen war alles ein Strom. Man kann sich das so vorstellen, wie von mir ist das letzte Dokument und dahinter stehend liegt das nächste Dokument und so geht das in aller Ewigkeit nach hinten, in so einer leichten Kurve nach links oben. Und da konnte man dann so vor und zurückfahren und dann konnte man sagen, jetzt nur Mail, weil Mail unterscheidet sich ja implizit und nicht durch die Applikation, mit der ich gearbeitet habe, oder jetzt nur Rechnungen, oder jetzt nur Bilder und so weiter, und jetzt nur dieses Projekt oder so. Also auf diese Art und Weise hat man seinen Strom gefiltert und dann da drin wieder vor und zurück gefahren. Eine eigentlich sehr schöne Idee, ohne jede Chance, sich jemals durchzusetzen, also aus jetziger Sicht.
Was sind andere Konzepte, die so...
Ja, es gab dieses Document-Centered, den Document-Centered-Approach, den gab es schon auch. Da gibt es sogar eine eher halbherzige Implementierung. Opendoc hieß die von Apple. Und IBM, stimmt, ja.
Sehr halbherzig. Sehr halbherzig.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Und es war unendlich lahm. Es war nie verständlich, warum es so lahm war. Aber es war wirklich, wirklich langsam. Und ich habe versucht es zu mögen damals, aber es ist mir nicht gelungen.
Ich denke, an der Stelle wird es aber auch wirklich... Das mit Opnok fand ich, war wirklich auch ein Schaltern der Software an sich, weil da lag es bestimmt nicht am User. Es war einfach nicht mehr klar, womit man denn dann eigentlich beginnt. Wenn man jetzt heute in Programmen denkt, in Anwendungen, die man gewohnt ist, die ja dann auch ihr eigenes Werkzeugset mitkriegen, die man auch erstmal kennen muss. Klar mag Word nicht immer das beste Tool sein, um irgendwie ein White Paper für irgendwas zu erstellen, wenn es auch andere Tools gibt, die darauf spezialisiert sind und das mit den Grafiken schöner und einfacher machen. Aber natürlich ist ein Werkzeug, von dem ich weiß, wie ich es zu bedienen habe oder dessen Schwächen ich zumindest kenne, ist dann natürlich in meiner Hand sehr viel effektiver als etwas anderes, was ich nicht kenne. Und in dem Moment, wo man so ein dokumentenzentriertes Ding macht, ist man eben nicht mehr bei seinen Werkzeugen. Man beginnt nicht mit den Werkzeugen an dem Dokument an, das Dokument soll sich aus sich selbst heraus erschaffen. Und da fehlt dann auch immer so ein bisschen der Ansatz, wo geht es denn jetzt eigentlich los? Wo bin ich zu Hause? Was ist mein Tool?
Konzeptuell war die Idee schon immer, dass man eigene Werkzeuge hat. Der Ausgangspunkt war immer dieses weiße leere Blatt. Aber du hast dir deine Werkzeuge geholt. Du willst jetzt etwas bohren, also gehst du in die Werkstatt und du möchtest etwas sägen, also gehst du zu diesem Tisch, wo du das einklemmst und du möchtest etwas schreiben, also setze dich an einen Schreibtisch. Du warst immer als erstes Raum über den Schreibtisch leer. Und dann, welche Werkzeuge werde ich denn jetzt brauchen? Dann muss man halt die Säge holen gehen und dann muss man halt die Bohrmaschine holen gehen. Im Endeffekt bin ich davon nicht überzeugt. Ich glaube, ich gehe lieber in die Werkstätte, um etwas zu bohren und zu sägen und setze mich an meinen Tisch, um etwas zu schreiben und ich gehe in die Küche, um etwas zu kochen. Ich glaube, da steckt schon etwas drinnen. Wir sind ein bisschen so. Dieses Dokument, es ist nicht alles ein Dokument. Es wird vielleicht einmal ein Dokument, aber am Anfang ist es nicht ein Dokument. Ich glaube, das ist auch das, was du beschreibst. Man ist am Anfang so verloren, weil man am falschen Ende beginnt. Man beginnt eben nicht damit zu sagen, es ist irgendwie von hinten anfangen, so zu tun, als wäre es schon fertig, sich vorzustellen und es dann einzufüllen.
Wenn ich irgendwas als wirklich gescheitertes Konzept ansehe, dann ist es diese Desktop-Metapher als solche. Ich habe meinen Computer noch nie wie meinen Schreibtisch gesehen. Geschweige denn, dass mein Schreibtisch in irgendeiner Form eine Ähnlichkeit hatte mit meinem Computer, abgesehen davon, dass alles in einem heillosen Durcheinander war. Tatsächlich, weil ich mit Computern besser umgehen kann, ist eigentlich die Ordnung in meinem Rechner größer als auf meinem Schreibtisch. Bis alle acht Monate oder so, wo ich das dann mal wieder gerade gebogen bekomme, so wird es hier wahrscheinlich den meisten höher rangehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so funktioniert. Ich habe einen Papierkorb und so, der stand noch nie auf meinem Schreibtisch.
Ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Ordner bei mir auf dem Schreibtisch auf dem Computer-Destop gefunden, der hieß wegräumen. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, oh ja, da habe ich schon mal alles reingetan. Da hatte ich eine Präsentation und da musste ich etwas herzeigen. Da wollte ich nicht, dass der so unordentlich ist. Und da habe ich alles unter Beibehaltung der Position, mit einem guten Trick hineingetan. Da habe ich hineingeschaut, da drin lag ein Ordner, der hieß wegräumen. Das ging sieben Ebenen, wirklich sieben Ebenen. Da waren Dinge drinnen, von denen habe ich gar nicht mehr gewusst, dass ich es auf meinem Computer habe. Aber in manchen dieser Ebenen hatte ich schon mal Zugriff seitdem, weil ich hingefunden habe über die Suche. Ich glaube, man muss die Desktop-Metapher anders sehen. Man muss die Desktop-Metapher als ein Constraint im Design sehen. Genauso wie den Folder und den Misskübel. Das waren Vorgaben an die, die Software gemacht haben. Das waren Vorgaben, die den Raum dessen, was man machen darf, ganz stark eingeschränkt haben auf sinnvolle Konzepte. Ich glaube auch, bevor ich einen Mac verwendet habe, habe ich zum ersten Mal noch nie einen Hängeordner gesehen. Ich kannte den Hängeordner aus dem Computer. Als ich ihn zum ersten Mal im Büro gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, das ist wie bei mir im Computer. Aber nichtsdestotrotz war es gut, dass diese Metapher da war. Sie hat alle, die Software gemacht haben, daran gehindert, schreckliche andere Konzepte sich auszudenken, die wir dann, wo wir keine Entsprechung mehr finden, vielleicht lernen, aber die dann jeder wieder ein anderes Konzept hat. Und von dem her, würde ich sagen, Desktop hin oder her, er hat schon sehr viel Gutes bewirkt.
Dein Beispiel mit dem Weckräumen finde ich super. Also erstens, weil ich auch solche Ordner habe, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie tief sie verschattelt sind. Ich glaube, bis sie verschattelt sind, sieben habe ich es noch nicht geschafft, aber da zeichnet sich ja noch was anderes ab. Dass nämlich diese Struktur, also ich würde jetzt mal unterstellen, als du diesen Ordner gefunden hast und du weißt, da ist jetzt sieben Mal Weckräumen drin, dass du im Prinzip mit den einzelnen Schritten auch insofern dann sehr viel anfängst, also dass du mit diesem einen Ordner, mit seinen ganzen anderen Ordnern eine Menge anfangen konntest, weil sie nämlich auch eine zeitliche Ordnung war.
Wir haben Geschichten erzählt. Jeder hänselt Desktop, eine Geschichte.
Genau, und das ist etwas, was ich generell eigentlich vermisse beim Computer und bei diesem Desktop, OS wie auch immer es heißen mag und wo es auch immer seine Menülzahle hinmalt. Mir fehlt einfach die Zeit, mir fehlt die Vergangenheit, mir fehlt der Fluss meines Arbeitens, den es eigentlich so wunderbar abspeichern könnte. Der ist nicht drin. Also, letzte Sendung hatten wir auch gerade hier nochmal über Versionssysteme geredet und wie man sie für die tägliche Arbeit vielleicht einsetzen könnte. Auch so Backup-Strategien jetzt auf dem Mac, was ihr sicherlich auch kennt, so Time Machine, was ja auch schon im Prinzip so eine zeitliche Organisation bietet und wo man dann so ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit fliegt, nur so für die eigentliche Arbeit. Ist das noch viel zu wenig mit drin. Also es gibt zwar so Ando-Historien, so ein bisschen. Das macht dann auch jedes Programm irgendwie anders. Hier mein Audio-Editor, mit dem ich jetzt gerade die Sendung aufnehme, hat diese unangenehme Eigenschaft, dass ich zwar beliebig oft Ando machen kann, aber wenn ich das Dokument das erste Mal speicher, das dann sofort wieder vergisst. Anstatt das einfach mitzuspeichern, weil ich natürlich auch nach dem Speichern vielleicht nochmal auf diese Arbeit zurückgreifen will, weil sie ja auch Teil meiner Arbeit ist. Also dieses Ändern selber, der eigentliche Prozess selbst, wird vom Computer, für meinen Geschmack, viel zu wenig gewürdigt. Es zählt immer nur die Momentaufnahme, der letzte Stand, und dass das, was man aber vorher gemacht hat, auch sehr wertvoll sein kann, wird eigentlich gar nicht honoriert.
Ich glaube, da sieht man zwei, drei Dinge an dem, was du jetzt sagst. Das eine ist Ando ist eine der großartigsten Errungenschaften des Computers ever. Wenn es einen Altar oder einen Siegerstockerl gibt, wo an erster Stelle jemand steht, was hat unser Computer gebracht, würde ich Ando ganz oben hinstellen. Ando ist unglaublich.
Tentenkiller und Radiergummi fand ich damals auch schon toll.
Aber Ando ist so viel besser. Dann muss man natürlich auch alle gleich ins Exil schicken, die Ando kaputt machen. Weil in Wirklichkeit gibt es überhaupt keinen Grund, warum ich nicht Ando vier Wochen lang zurück machen kann. Warum kann ich nicht Ando safe machen? Aber da kommen wir natürlich zum anderen Punkt. Safe ist eins der schrecklichsten Überblebsel, die wir aus diesen Architekturen haben. Safe, das Abspeichern, ist ein entsetzlicher Rest von Technologie, der uns geblieben ist, den überhaupt niemand mehr braucht. Und es gab Anwendungen, die hatten keinen sicheren Hypercard. Viele Jahre lang habe ich Hypercard gebastelt ohne Ende. Wir hatten ein unglaubliches System hier im Laufen mit Hypercard verfügbar.
Also Hypercard muss man dazu sagen.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben das mit Web gemacht.
Eine Desktop-Database und Hyperlinks.
Genau, aber sehr grafisch. Man konnte das mit Bleistift, aber nur Schwarz-Weiß draufkreuzen.
Feinmaker hat auch keinen Safe.
Genau, aber das hatte keinen Safe. Und alles, was man gemacht hat, war und es war auch nicht irgendwie schwierig. Man hat halt dann mal eine Kopie gemacht.
Es ist halt immer gescheitert.
Ja, genau. Und das war mit Disketten schon kein Problem. Also ich sehe da ein übrig Bleibsel an Technologie, von dem wir uns auch geistig einfach offensichtlich nicht lösen können.
Eigentlich will man, dass der Rechner immer speichert, bloß dass man ab und zu mal sagen kann, der Stand, so wie er jetzt ist, heißt.
Zum Beispiel.
Hat eine Versionsnummer, um dem Beispiel zu bleiben.
Beispielsweise wäre es ein schönes Modell. Man könnte auch einfach sagen, der Strom bleibt und ich kann dann in den Strom zurückgreifen und sagen, hier mache ich jetzt weiter oder hier klebe ich einen Kleber hin oder was auch immer.
Aber es gibt nichts. Wir haben immer noch Mäuse und Fenster und Save.
Ja und nein. Das Web macht das schon ein bisschen anders. Jetzt so Ajax-Anwendungen im Web, die sind zum Teil schon so, dass man nicht mehr speichert. Die haben einfach alles. Man macht da und schreibt und wenn man wiederkommt, ist es...
Na ja, zum Teil. Aber auch Google Docs hat noch ein Save-Button.
Auch Google Docs? Ja gut, die müssen halt so gut wie möglich tun, als wären sie in Wirklichkeit Word, was ja in Wirklichkeit eine schreckliche Vorgabe ist. Ich würde ja so gerne so eine Open-Source-Textverarbeitung verwenden, wenn sie nicht alle so entsetzlich versuchen würden, wie Word zu sein. Word ist ein elendes Vorbild. Und da zeigt sich irgendwie auch die Grenze der Open-Source, ich würde fast sagen Bewegung. Da fehlen Kompetenzen. Und damit das Selbstbewusstsein gestaltet, hier einzugreifen und zu sagen, wir schaffen was ganz Neues. Das gibt es manchmal so in Ecken.
Interessant davon, dass wir ruhig mal bleiben, weil das ist natürlich auch immer wieder in Debatten. Open-Source und User-Interface-Design. Geht das generell nicht zusammen oder was ist das Problem?
Ich kann ein Problem beschreiben. Ein Problem ist, dass Code ein ganz schlechtes Designmaterial ist. Und Code ist die zentrale Währung in Open-Source. Wenn du bei Open-Source mitmachen willst, machst du eigentlich am Code mit. Code ist ein schlechtes Designmaterial. Code ist, wie der Buchdruck das Denken verändert hat, so verändert Code das Denken. Und Code verändert Denken auf eine Art und Weise, dass man wegkommt von den Menschen, die damit arbeiten, und hinkommt zu den technischen Strukturen, die man schaffen muss und die man verwalten und bändigen muss, damit dieses Ding überhaupt funktioniert. Und je mehr man codet, umso mehr kommt man davon weg. Wenn man dann so Texte liest, wo es dann um Aunt Tilly geht, die versucht, einen Drucker einzurichten, und ich habe mal eine ausführliche Kritik davon geschrieben, von diesem Raymond Chandler Vorfall mit Aunt Tilly, oder schreibt das auf... Meine Güte, das ist schon lange her.
Tilly mit T-I-L-L-I-E.
Und wenn man dann hört, wie sie über den non-technical user reden, mit diesem Aunt Tilly...
Auf Deutsch heißt das DAU.
Genau, und das ist ein entschrecklicher Begriff, der DAU. Ganz furchtbar. Und solange diese Denke da ist, wird kein gutes User-Interface sein stehen. Gutes User-Interface, gutes Interaktions-System, gutes Software gibt Menschen Macht und Reichtum, also jetzt nicht finanziell, sondern in ihren Möglichkeiten. Schafft Räume, macht Dinge möglich, von denen sie vorher nicht geträumt haben. Wenn man die als dümmsten anzunehmenden User betrachtet und so behandelt, dann kommt nichts dabei raus. Und das Einzige, was dabei rauskommt, ist, und ich meine, ich sehe schon die Mailberge sich bei mir anhäufen, wenn die Leute sich das anhören, aber das, was dabei rauskommt, ist wirklich gute Imitationen von anderen Produkten.
So wie OpenOffice zum Beispiel.
Die wirklich gut funktionieren, aber ich kann sie trotzdem nicht verwenden, weil ich alte Word schon nicht aus.
Ja, das geht mir genauso. Gibt es keine Gegenbeispiele?
Doch, ich glaube, es gibt Gegenbeispiele. Es gibt kleine Projekte, einzelne, die anders laufen, aber ich habe jetzt kein Präsent oder Parat, das ja auch schon sprechend ist. Man stolpert immer wieder mal über was, und man sich denkt, das ist aber nett. Aber das sind dann eher so einzelne Grübchen von Leuten, die sich zusammentun und die verstehen, dass man da anders herangehen muss und die das dann machen und dann schnell in das Open Source. Ich glaube, aus dieser großen Narrative des Open Source-Prozesses, da kann kein gutes Interview-Design entstehen. Das ist das Problem.
Wobei, ich meine, wir leben ja in zunehmendem Maße da auch einen kulturellen Wandel, wo vorher die Freiheit des Codes die Hauptrolle gespielt hat in dieser ganzen Bewegung. Wir jetzt mit Creative Commons, offenen Lizenzierungsmodellen, zunehmendem Public Domain-Gedanken und auch freien Zugang zum Wissen, eigentlich auch ganz andere kulturelle Werte auf einmal versuchen, im selben Bereich einzusteigen. Vielleicht ist das ja die Tür, die sich irgendwann mal öffnet, um dann auch diese Mensch-Maschine-Interface zu neuem Ergebnis zu machen. Warum sind denn die nicht-Open-Source-Strukturen so viel besser oder kompetitiver an der Stelle? Was ist es? Ist das wirklich dieses Firmen-Kunden-Verhältnis?
Nein, nein, es ist eine Art zu denken. Es ist eine Art im Design zu denken. Das ist das...
Wie muss man denn denken?
Ja, wie muss man denn denken?
Das ist eine ganz schwierige Frage. Ich sage mal, über diesen Begriff des Design-Thinking gibt es seit ein, zwei Jahren intensive Diskussionen und intensive Auseinandersetzungen damit. Es gibt ein paar Firmen, die haben sich mit Design selber aus dem Dreck gezogen. Ganz vorweg das Paradebeispiel natürlich immer, das man eigentlich schon nicht mehr hören kann, ist Apple mit dem iPod und den darauf folgenden Veränderungen auch des Restes. Aber auch Samsung ist ein ganz ausgezeichnetes Beispiel. Samsung hat gerade einen Design-Eward mehr gewonnen als Apple bei irgendeiner dieser Veranstaltungen. Die haben vor 15 Jahren gesagt, wir stellen Design in die Mitte unseres Unternehmens. Design-Thinking und wir wollen gut gestaltete Dinge machen. Und vorausgekommen ist eine Firma, die sich auch damit selber aus dem Dreck gezogen hat. Damals haben alle gelacht, heute sieht man, es ist eine Erfolgstrategie. Auch Philips hat so Ecken, wo gutes Design passiert und wo sie mit gutem Design spielen. Und manchmal kommen auch solche Produkte heraus. Sony war lange Zeit dafür gerühmt, dass sie mit gutem Design spielen. Die hatten aber immer eher dieses, kennst du diese Citruspresse von Philip Stark? Ja, genau. Die hatten immer eher dieses hinterher aufgetakte, damit es gut ausschaut Design. Und nicht notwendigerweise dieses Design, das sich durch alles durchzieht.
Die Zitronenpresse funktioniert nicht gut?
Die Zitronenpresse ist ein entsetzliches Ding. Die Citruspresse ist deswegen entsetzlich, weil sie rumrutscht, weil man so viel Kraft anbringt. Das ist aber nicht das eigentliche Problem. Wenn sie rumrutscht, stößt man das Glas um, weil diese Spitze unten in das Glas hinein steht. Und wenn sie dann rutscht, stößt man das Glas um. Aber das wirklich schlimme Problem ist, dass die Kerne alle reinfallen. Jede normale Orangen- oder Zitronenpresse hat so einen Ring von Stäbchen oder was auch immer. Ein Netz, ein Sieb, was auch immer. Und da fallen die einfach alle ins Glas. Und damit ist sie ein kompletter Versager. Form follows function. Sie ist kein Versager, was die Form angeht. Und wenn ich mir dieses Ding in meine Küche stelle, dann erzähle ich damit eine Geschichte. Und dadurch, dass es unbenutzt ist, erzähle ich eine noch tollere Geschichte. Dass es ganz sauber bleibt. Und vielleicht kommt irgendwann mein Chef zu mir und zieht das Ding und denkt dann besser von mir.
Das ist die Maschine mit dem Bing.
Das ist die Maschine mit dem Bing, vielleicht. Aber es ist... Design hat immer viele... Dinge haben immer mehrere Funktionen. Da gibt es nicht nur die Funktion, dessen, wie es arbeitet, sondern auch ein Zeichen, das es setzt, ein Symbol in der Welt. Und da gibt es auch ein paar andere Bedeutungen, die Dinge anhaften. Und da spielt Design eine vielfältige Rolle. Und wenn man da nicht ganz nach unten durchdringt und sagt, Design ist die Seele des Dings, die sich dann heraus äußert, indem wir es ausschaut und indem wir damit arbeiten, dann kommt man nicht hin. Und das bedeutet aber, dass man den gesamten Entwicklungsprozess auf den Kopf stellen muss. Erst einmal alles wegwerfen, den Tisch leer räumen und sagen, wie wollen wir denn, dass die Leute damit tun? Was wollen wir denn überhaupt, dass die Leute damit tun? Wie kommen die denn zu uns? Was für Erwartungen haben die? Und wie können wir dem, wollen wir dem gerecht werden? Wie wollen wir uns damit auseinandersetzen? Und beginnend von der Perspektive der Menschen, die dann damit arbeiten, kann man dann anfangen, den Prozess von hinten aufzurollen und Dinge zu entwickeln, die für die Leute sind und nicht für den Markt.
Was würdest du denn so Software-Entwicklern, ich meine, ich würde ja den Software-Entwicklern, also den Open-Source-Geschmeten gar nicht mal unterstellen, dass das ihr Ziel ist, ein schlechtes User-Interface zu machen.
Überhaupt nicht. Nein, im Gegenteil.
Was könnte man denn tun? Also ich meine, wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, ist es erst mal dieses vom Menschen her, also vom Anwender her denken. Gut, das klingt jetzt erst mal ein bisschen einfach und ich denke, viele glauben das auch zu tun, aber finden sich dann aber trotzdem nicht in der richtigen Rolle wieder offensichtlich oder machen auf dem Weg irgendwelche Fehler. Was sind denn so die Milestones?
Das einfachste, was man tun kann, ist professionelle Hilfe suchen. Ich fürchte, dass es kein einfaches Rezept gibt, wie ein Apple ID gibt es der Dr. Away oder irgend sowas. Es ist ein Umdenken, das man schaffen muss, ein Anderssetzen der Prioritäten. Solange man codet, schafft man das nicht. Da kann man auch theoretisch zu begründen, warum das so ist. Code ist nicht ambivalent. Ambivalenz braucht beim Design wie ein Stück Brot.
Du hast ja schon die Sherwer-Szene des McIntosh gelobt, wo das offensichtlich besser funktioniert.
Genau, wo das einzelne kleine Entwickler sind, die alles unter Kontrolle haben, die fangen anders an. Die beginnen damit, sich zu überlegen, wie das Ding sein soll. Da gibt es so eine nette kleine Software. Wie heißt die noch? Provcast heißt die. Provcast ist eine Software, mit der man Präsentationen aufzeichnet. Man nimmt das Audio zusammen mit der Präsentation auf, während man sie macht. Und am Schluss hat man dann so einen...
Macht Podcasts und so.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Ja, genau. Und die haben... Ich glaube, wenn ich das... Das finde ich jetzt nicht draus. Da gibt es eine Interview, mit denen die Provcast gemacht haben. Und die haben dort erklärt, wie viele Skizzen sie gemacht haben, bevor sie begonnen haben, das Ding umzusetzen. Das ist wirklich eine kleine Software, mit einem begrenzten Funktionsumfang. Viel mehr als... Man muss es dann halt noch... Man sagt einen Encoder und dann kann man es noch umcoden, nach MP3 oder was auch immer, und abspeichern, das war's. Und die haben, ich finde es jetzt nicht so, wie 5000 Skizzen gemacht. Oder 2500, ja.
Wir finden den Link und den finden wir dann alle in den begleitenden Notes hier zu der Sendung.
Ja, den Podcast, den kann ich schon sagen. Also das sage ich dir nachher, ja. Design Critique heißt der Podcast. Products for People, und das ist die Folge 36. Ja genau, ProfCast & Software Designed, Humble Daisy. Das ist aber eine Stunde 17, da werden wir jetzt nicht rausfinden. Das ist den Quot auf die Schnelle. Also das ist einmal ein guter Ansatz. Man nimmt sich zum Beispiel das letzte Buch von Bill Buxton her, den wir vollkommen übersprungen haben in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Der Bill Buxton ist jetzt Head of Research bei Microsoft und ist einer der großen Hintergrundkreativen Köpfe in der Geschichte der Mensch-Maschine-Kommunikation. Ich würde sagen, Videoconferencing und Multitouch sind zwei Konzepte, von denen ich behaupten würde, dass die wesentlichen Erscheinungsformen, wie es heute ist, auf ihn zurückgehen. Jetzt muss ich noch sagen, das letzte Buch heißt Sketching User Experiences und das ist eins, wo man mal anfangen kann. Wenn man sich das anschaut, da steht drin, wie man an diese Design-Fragen herangeht und wie man erst einmal das ganze technische Zeug aus seinem Hirn rauskriegt bis zur Selbstentblösung, bis zum Extrem. Und dann kann man anfangen, die Dinge von einer anderen Seite zu sehen.
Also User Interface Design ist eigentlich die totale Askese, um sich erst einmal nackt auszuziehen und eine Stunde in die Büsse setzen.
Genau, wenn man vorher nichts anderes gemacht als gecodet, dann würde ich das schon empfehlen.
Ja, und vielleicht noch irgendeine Diät. So eine mentale Diät. Jetzt hast du es angesprochen und das ist der Punkt, auf den wir auf jeden Fall eingehen müssen. Multitouch und natürlich das iPhone als jüngstes Phänomen eines bahnbrechenden Geräts, weil es mal wieder sehr schnell sehr populär ist. Und darüber hinaus, über seinen eigenen Erfolg, merkt man ja auch sofort die Auswirkungen auf die gesamte andere Produktwelt. Hatten wir vor kurzem noch Telefone, die effektiv nicht benutzbar waren, geht jetzt auf einmal alles in diese Richtung. Apple ist angetreten mit dem Modell, wo wir vorhin diese ganzen Geräte hatten, mit den fest definierten Knöpfen, hin zu einem Gerät ohne irgendwelche Knöpfe, ohne Tastatur, also bis auf einen eigentlich, wenn man jetzt mal so von Lautstärke und sowas absieht, wo dann eben alles im Finger liegt. Und ich meine, über sowas wurde ja schon auch immer lange geredet. Bill Gates hat eigentlich seit Mitte der 90er Jahre immer davon fabuliert, dass jetzt dann doch mal der Tablettcomputer kommt und dann warteten alle und kam wieder nichts. Das ist jetzt im Prinzip der erste, wo das so ist. Der erste Computer, kann man sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Computer überhaupt noch die richtige Bezeichnung dafür ist, aber es ist natürlich technisch einer. Worauf wollte ich hinaus? Ah ja, genau. Dieses Paradigma des Touch und des Multitouch. Welche Dimension eröffnet das jetzt? Wie siehst du das?
Ich habe mich lange geweigert, so ein Ding zu haben, weil ich der Meinung war, dass Mobiltelefone uninteressante Geräte sind, die nur lästige Situationen erzeugen. Und das war auch lange Zeit so. Ich habe auch jahrelang unter Mobiltelefonen gelitten. Ich hatte welche von Nokia und von Motorola, das war das Schlimmste überhaupt. Und alle diese Geräte haben sich in jeglicher Form der vernünftigen Bedienung ganz einfacher Dinge einfach verweigert. Das war entsetzlich eichartig, aber auch ein so ein Ergsen. Das war überhaupt schlimm. Und dann war ich vor zwei Jahren, so knapp nachdem das iPhone rausgekommen ist, das ist jetzt zwei Jahre, oder? Ungefähr, war ich in Bologna bei einem Jahresversammlung von Technical Authors, von den Leuten, die die Handbücher schreiben. Und da war jemand von Nokia. Und die hat die Geschichte erzählt, wie das war, als sie das iPhone bekommen haben. In dieser Abteilung der Technik-Authoren.
Als das erste Mal sozusagen eingereicht wurde.
Da ist dann zu Nokia jemand gekommen mit diesem Bagger und die haben das dann aufgemacht. Und sie waren komplett fertig, denn es war kein Handbuch drin. Und das war richtig schlimm für die. Und vorher hatten sie schon diese Videos gesehen, wo vierjährige Kinder mit dem iPhone im Sofa sitzen und die Slideshows anschauen und die Bilder drehen und alles das. Also die waren richtig fertig. Und in Wirklichkeit müsste eins dabei sein, muss man jetzt sagen. Dass keins dabei ist, ist wirklich nur dieses Statement. Wir brauchen keins. Ihr schafft es schon. Das ist lustig. Beim iPod Touch ist einer dabei. Da gibt es ein kleines Leporello, so ein gefalteter Zettel, wo die Grunddinge erklärt werden. Dass, wenn man lang drauf bleibt, dass sie dann so zu wiggling anfangen und dass man sie dann zwischen den Seiten herumschieben kann. Das ist ja was, was man eigentlich zuerst einmal nicht findet. Aber beim iPhone ist einfach kein Handbuch dabei. Und ich glaube, das ist, wenn man jetzt einmal davon absieht, dass es ein unglaublich arrogantes und fettes Statement gegenüber dem Rest der Mobilkommunikationsindustrie ist, ist es zum Teil auch etwas, was sie sich natürlich erlauben können, weil sie eine Community haben, von denen sie wissen, dass die Leute zurückfallen, wenn sie sich wohl nicht auskennen. Jeder kennt jemand, der hat seit 20 Jahren einen Mac und natürlich als Erster das iPhone gehabt. Und der kann alle Fragen beantworten. Also sie verlassen sich da auch auf ihre Community.
Meinst du das wirklich?
Ja, ganz sicher sogar.
Ist das nicht so, dass sie sich eher darauf verlassen, dass das iPhone immer Internet hat und man da nachschauen kann?
Ach, wenn diese Dinge mal zum Zittern anfangen, dann gibt es keinen Nachschauen mehr. Dann hat es ein Virus, wie mir mal jemand gesagt hat. Also da verlässt man sich schon drauf.
Na gut, da muss ja auch erstmal was gelungen sein. Die Frage ist ja, was bringt Touch und dann spezifisches Multitouch-Noise auf die Kälte?
Ich sage jetzt einmal das eine, Touch hat seine Grenzen. Touch hat ganz klare Grenzen dort, wo der Finger das verdeckt, was ich touche. Und die Auflösung dessen, was ich touche, ist ebenfalls sehr begrenzt. Ich kann davon ausgehen, dass die Auflösung hoch genug ist, mein Finger löst nicht höher auf. Also ich kann nicht mehr tun, als mein Finger auflöst. Das sind einmal die Grenzen. Gleichzeitig eröffnet sich die Möglichkeit, und ich finde, das ist auch das, was sie wirklich gut umgesetzt haben, einer vollkommen neuen Art der Interaktion mit dem, was da drinnen ist. Also dieses Entirely Shaped by Software, was hier umgesetzt ist, mit dieser einzigen Home-Taste, die außen ist. Das ist nicht nur etwas, was sich jetzt findet als abgehakt, sondern das ist etwas, was sie ernst genommen haben und gesagt haben, ok, jetzt haben wir hier diese Inhalte und wir wollen, dass man mit dem Finger damit jetzt so tut. Und da gibt es von Jonas Löfgren aus Schweden, ein sehr netter Kollege aus Malmö, der hat vor ein paar Jahren begonnen, ästhetische Begriffe der Interaktion zu definieren. Der hat gesagt, wir kennen ästhetische Begriffe, der Typografie zum Beispiel. Wir wissen, dass Farben zusammen passen können, dass dann ästhetisch, oder wir wissen, dass wir ästhetisch angezogen sein können oder auch nicht. Und wir haben dafür eigene Begriffe. Fest zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Begriff hier in Österreich, für jemand, der ästhetisch gekleidet ist und gut ausschaut. Aber wir haben keine Begriffe für die Ästhetik der Interaktion. Ja, das ist aber eine Übertragung. Und er hat begonnen, solche Begriffe zu schaffen. Der zentrale Begriff hier ist Playability. Playability bedeutet sowas Ähnliches wie Geschmeidigkeit. Und das ist genau das, was das iPhone am besten beschreibt. Die Interaktion mit dem iPhone ist geschmeidig. Das Scrollen, das Bremsen des Scrollen. Google Earth auf dem iPhone ist unglaublich. Jetzt kann man diesen ganzen Bogen ziehen. Es gibt einen Wiener Stadtplan, der zur Verfügung gestellt wird von dem Bundesrechenzentrum. Da steht irgendwo so ein riesiger alter Kasten. Dann schicke ich so einen Request hin, indem ich eine Adresse eingebe. Dann rechnet der ein Bild. Und dieses Bild schickt er dann an meinen Computer zurück. Online. Web. Und da steht dann das Bild. Und wenn ich da jetzt irgendwo hin klicke, klicke ich in das Bild, um den Mittelpunkt zu verschieben. Wenn ich da irgendwo hin klicke, geht eine neue Query an diesen Server. Dauert Sekunden. Machen wir eine halbe Minute. Und dann kommt ein neues Bild zurück. Die Seite wird neu geladen. Und jetzt, wenn man jetzt den Schritt geht von dem und dann Google Maps im Browser, wo man es ein bisschen rumschiebt und es lädt so dynamisch nach, war das ja schon irre. Das ist ein gutes Stück geschmeidiger. Und dann nimmt man Google Earth. Weiss nicht, hast du schon Stunden vor Google Earth verbracht?
Tage. Wochen.
Wahnsinn. Und was hier wirklich so überzeugend ist, in der Art und Weise, wie man umgeht, ist die Geschmeidigkeit der Interaktion. Und dann kommt das iPhone und setzt ihm noch einen drauf. Und dann, ah, das fühlt sich ja gut an. Sehr unglaublich. Und das ist, diese Ästhetik der Interaktion, die haben sie, wie man sagt, nailed. Die haben sie wirklich hingekriegt. Ich glaube, irgendeiner von diesen amerikanischen Tech-Journalisten hat einmal gesagt, wenn sie sechs Monate nur an dem Scrollen gearbeitet haben, bis sie das richtig haben, dann war das die Arbeit wert. Weil das Scrollen ist so unglaublich gut in diesem Ding. Die Kontrolle, die man hat, dieses Schupfen und Bremsen, langsam und schnell, dieses im Browser gleichzeitig Zoomen und Scrollen. Unglaublich. Wir arbeiten so ein bisschen in diesem Multitouch-Bereich. Wir haben einen Diplomaten, der übrigens einen ganz großartigen Tracker macht, für diese Multitouch-Dinge. Touche, der wahrscheinlich schnellste Tracker, weil er Single-Plattform ist.
Tracker von Handbewegungen oder Kamera.
Genau, von diesen Lichtpunkten, die da entstehen. Der Übersetzer sind Koordinaten und der verwendet OS X Core-Technologien, Core Video, Core Image, um diese Manipulationen zu machen. Und er kommt auf mehrere tausend Frames pro Sekunde auf einfache Maschinen. Und da haben wir jetzt einen Kollegen, der als Diplomarbeit so eine Gestenerkennungsengine schreiben soll. Und an diesem gleichzeitig drehen, zoomen und verschieben, da beißt man sich schon einmal die Zähne aus. Das ist gar nicht so einfach, wenn man da versucht, mathematisch dahinter zu kommen und gleichzeitig noch andere Gesten zuzulassen. Also was sie da gemacht haben, ist ganz, ganz, ganz erstaunlich. Sie haben ja auch diesen, da gab es eine kleine Multitouch-Firma, diese. Finger, nur diese vier Finger, und dann so drehen war Copy. Und in die andere Richtung drehen war Paste. Aber wenn man jetzt diesen Finger her tut und den da, also lauter abstrakte Gesten, ganz entsetzlich. Genau, aber mit einer Bewegung dazu noch. Und der hat irgendwie einen Weg gefunden, über den Abstand diese Finger voneinander zu unterscheiden. Und da konnte man dann eine riesige Menge von verschiedenen Gesten unterscheiden, die sich niemand merken konnte. Den und seine Technologie haben sie sich gekauft und das ist wohl die Basis von iPhone Multi-Touch. Danke.
Wenn man noch mal recherchieren kommt in die Links. Tja und jetzt, ich meine, ist das jetzt so, es gibt ja auch noch Sachen, die außerhalb sind. Also das Andu, was wir schon hatten beim iPhone, ist ja dann schütteln. Ja, da geht es dann komplett aus dem Gerät, also vom Bildschirm zumindest weg. Was, ja was steckt da drin für die Zukunft?
Ja, da muss man schon auch die anderen dazunehmen. Die Playstation-Kamera da oben drauf, wo man da rumpeckt.
Weißt du eigentlich, was die Rolle von dem Jeff Hahn war? Der ist ja ein, zwei Jahre bevor das iPhone rauskam, mit diesen Demo-Videos von Multitouch recht bekannt geworden. Wo ja eigentlich diese ganzen Sachen, die du jetzt auch gerade so beschrieben hast, mit Ausnahme des Scrollings, glaube ich, aber zumindest für dieses Google-Earth-artige Zoomen, durcheinander schieben und so weiter, das war ja im Prinzip alles drin zu sehen.
Ja, also ich glaube...
War das nur eine Demo? Ich glaube, Apple hatte da schon einige...
Ja, ja, ja, ich glaube, das hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Die haben das schon... Es gibt Multitouch-Literatur bis in die 70er Jahre, die Späten. Das kann man finden auf der Seite von Bill Baxen. billbaxen.com, da gibt es eine übersichtige Literatur zur Multitouch und da findet man das zurück bis in die 80er Jahre. Also, was der Jeff Hahn gemacht hat, war, er hat meines Wissens dieses Frustrated Total Internal Reflection Prinzip. Na, das ist das technische Prinzip hinter seinen Multitouch-Tischen. Du hast diese Glasscheibe und du schießt von der Seite Licht hinein. Und weil der Winkel, indem das reflektiert wird, so klein oder so groß ist, je nachdem, wie man es anschaut, darum geht das nicht hinaus aus der Glasscheibe, sondern wie Glasfaserkabel, welt das da so vor sich hin, immer von oben und unten reflektiert. Wenn man jetzt einen Finger drauf hält, dann verändert man das Verhalten so, dass ein Teil dieses Lichts nach unten reflektiert wird. Also, man weiß, wo der Finger ist. Genau. Und wenn man das jetzt mit Infrarot macht, dann kann man das sehr schön tracken, wo das geht. Man kann kein Sonnenlicht reinlassen, weil wenn man Sonnenlicht reinlässt, dann ist zu viel Infrarot da, das funktioniert dann schon nicht mehr. Also, das ist ein sehr instabiles Prinzip. Die Schilder, die man nach diesem Prinzip baut, die brauchen meistens kontrollierte Bedingungen. Und er hat das zur Perfektion gebracht und hat dann mit ausreichend Rechenleistung tolle Demos gemacht, wo er diese Bilder herumgeschupft hat und all diese Dinge, aber keine einzige wirkliche Anwendung gezeigt, die irgendwie spannend war. Wir haben uns das damals alle fasziniert angeschaut und gesagt, das ist die Zukunft, das kommt jetzt. Und dann, wenn man sich die Demo das dritte Mal anschaut und der steht da vor dieser Wand und tut herum, dann beginnt man darüber nachzudenken, wenn man jetzt eine halbe Stunde vor dieser Wand steht und mit seinen Händen da herumschiebt, dann fallen einem die Arme auch ab. Und irgendwo...
Und man kommt sich auch ein bisschen affig vor.
Ja, und das, was der da macht, ist eigentlich immer nur so Bilder herumschieben und hin und her. Und wo sind jetzt die Anwendungen? Wo ist jetzt das, wo wir sagen, wow, auf das haben wir gewartet?
Dafür lohnt es sich, um zu hampeln.
Es kommt noch, aber bis jetzt war es noch nicht da. Jetzt stehen sie im US-Fernseher und machen diese Wetterkarten größer und kleiner. Und so richtig überzeugen ist das auch noch nicht. Das bei dieser Obama-Inauguration, da sind sie ja da mit diesen tausenden Bildern, die sie da hatten, die sie da rein und raus. Und das war schon sehr beeindruckend, aber so richtig, dass ich jetzt sage, wow, so möchte ich auch, war es nicht. Also von dem her ist das schon noch das überzeugendste Stück Hardware, das iPhone.
Ähnlich geht es mir ja auch mit einem anderen User-Interface-Modell, was auch schon seit Ewigkeiten proklamiert wird und sich auch nicht so richtig durchsetzen will, das ist Spracherkennung, dass man halt so mit seinem Computer redet. Das ist aus demselben Gründen bei mir auch schon immer durchgefallen, dass ich einfach, was weiß ich, man hat neue Versionen von System XY, was es auch immer ist, dem Mac oder so, hat Spracherkennung. Dann probiert man das mal so zehn Minuten aus, stellt dann irgendwann fest, dass man Gott sei Dank noch alleine im Raum ist und der Gedanke, sich mit seinem Computer zu unterhalten, während noch andere Leute dabei zuschauen, hat mich dann in der Regel nicht überzeugt.
Also da gibt es ganz...
Da hat man aber auch so dieses Problem des Uncanny Valley, das Konzept, muss man vielleicht noch mal kurz erläutern, was ja so im 3D-Modeling-Bereich drin ist. Man kann dem sehr nahe kommen, dass man so realistische Menschen macht. Aber ganz kurz bevor man wirklich an der Perfektion ist, wird es so creepy, dass die Leute es ablehnen. Das heißt, man ist irgendwie ganz gut davor, so wie Pixar das macht. Und irgendwann ist man dann vielleicht auch im Perfekten, aber das mit der Perfektion ist ja immer so ein Problem. So und ähnliche Modelle sehe ich auch so bei User Interface.
Ankenivelli sind die Zombies. Die wurde sehr explizit ausgenutzt werden. Entschuldige, Zombies sind ja eigentlich Menschen, die nicht ganz so ausschauen wie Menschen. Und deswegen sind sie so unheimlich. Und kranke Menschen schauen auch aus wie Menschen und nicht ganz so. Und deswegen halten wir uns fern. Also da gibt es biologische Signale, die begründen, warum es dieses Ankenivelli gibt. Und sowas gibt es natürlich auch im User Interface-Design. Aber da kommt natürlich noch was anderes dazu. Ich glaube, Spracherkennung ist ein großer Pile of Failure, wie man so sagt. Weil wir, wie soll ich sagen, es gibt den Begriff der Effordance. Effordance ist, das sind die Dinge, die ich mir so vorstellen kann, damit zu tun. Das ist ein abstrakter Kunstbegriff, die Effordance. Aber das ist ein bisschen das, ich schaue das an, und dann denke ich mir, das kann ich damit machen. Ich schaue einen Hammer an, und dann will ich damit Nägel einschlagen. Oder wenn ich anders denke, dann will ich anderen Menschen die Köpfe damit einschlagen. Aber ich kann mir immer vorstellen, was ich damit tun kann und tun will. Die Effordance von natürlicher Sprache ist Kommunikation. Solange Kommunikation nicht geht, werden wir mit Computern nicht sprechen wollen, weil wir uns erwarten, dass das, was wir sagen können, auch verstanden wird. Wenn es diese Grenze nicht gibt, das iPhone kann ja diese Spracherkennung, aber ich mache das nie, weil ich nie weiß, was ich jetzt eigentlich sagen soll. Muss ich Vor- und Nachnamen sagen? Muss ich Call vorher sagen? Was ist es eigentlich? Die Effordance von natürlicher Sprache ist vollkommen unklar. Die ist eigentlich, dass ich jemand habe, der versteht, wenn ich mitnehmen Satz plötzlich umdrehe und das Subjekt verliere und das Prädikat ist irgendwo links liegen geblieben und Zeitwort habe ich auch keins mehr und trotzdem versteht es jemand. Das ist natürliche Sprache. Und das müssen die Computer hinkriegen. Wenn die Computer das hinkriegen, können wir mit ihnen reden. Vorher wird es nicht funktionieren, weil wir unsere Sprache bewusst dann umlernen müssen für dieses Ding. Eine eigene Sprache zum Sprechen mit dem Computer erlernen und das ist ein Vorgang, der ganz verletzlich ist. Auf einmal in Urlaub können wir es nicht mehr. Also ich glaube das nicht. Das funktioniert nicht. Natürliche Sprache funktioniert nicht.
Tja, wo geht es dir hin, die Reise? Wenn wir jetzt noch 20 Jahre lang Maus klicken, oder was?
Darf ich das nicht beantworten? Der Punkt ist der, dass mich das eigentlich nicht interessiert. Ein guter Teil meiner Arbeit in diesem Interaktionsdesign-Bereich, oder sagen wir, der Teil meiner Arbeit, der sich in diesem Interaktionsdesign-Bereich abspielt, spielt sich in der Gegenwart ab. Und mich interessiert, Dinge zu gestalten, zu entwickeln, und zu finden, die großartig sind, jetzt. Ein guter Teil dieser ganzen HCI-Community beschäftigt sich mit der 10-jährigen Zukunft oder der 20-jährigen Zukunft. Und ich habe absolut kein Verständnis dafür, weil ich nicht weiß, warum ich meine Energie da hineinstecken soll, wenn es in Wirklichkeit darum geht, jetzt Dinge zu machen, die Menschen ermöglichen, jetzt Großartiges damit zu tun.
Okay, und was ist da der spannendste Bereich? Das Web haben wir im Prinzip noch gar nicht so richtig erwähnt. Ist das nicht so jetzt der größte Notizblock, den man sich vorstellen könnte?
Das Web hat unglaubliches Potenzial, ganz großartige Dinge zu tun. Und wenn man sich dann so eine Google Wave-Demo anschaut, dann kriegt man ein bisschen einen Vorgeschmack von dem. Aber das ist auch jetzt, Google Wave. Wenn jemand vor fünf Jahren mir erzählt hätte, was wir in fünf Jahren vielleicht tun können, dann...
Dann wärst du begeistert gewesen.
Dann wär ich vielleicht begeistert gewesen, aber ich hätte mich wieder geärgert, weil ich meine Zeit verplempert hätte mit irgendwelchen Visionen. Wenn ich in Wirklichkeit an diesem Bank-Selbstbedienungs-Kiosket arbeiten sollen. Wo es viel wichtiger ist, dass das jetzt geht, dass die Leute ihre Überweisungen selber machen können oder sowas. Aber wenn man jetzt Google Wave anschaut und sagt, das haben wir im Herbst, dann ist das schon ganz begeistert. Und ich glaube, da steckt viel Potenzial drinnen, wiederum zu verändern, wie wir denken und wie wir arbeiten.
Warum bringst du jetzt ausgerechnet Google Wave als Beispiel? Weil da jetzt die Kommunikation noch so mit drin steht? Oder ist das jetzt rein vom User-Interface, vom GUI?
Nein, ich habe die Demo nur neben mir angeschaut. Ich habe das User-Interface gar nicht wirklich angeschaut. Es gibt so eine Kurzversion der Demo, die hat jemand zusammengeschnitten, sodass die wesentlichen Dinge drinnen sind. Was spannend ist, sind die Konzepte. Die Ausformung des Interfaces ist ja schließlich nur die äußerste Hülle. Gutes Design geht ja bis ganz nach innen. Gutes Design ist, was ich damit tun kann, wie die internen Strukturen gestaltet sind, sodass sie mir das machen lassen, was ich will. Vielleicht gebe ich ein ganz konkretes Beispiel. Wir haben für eine Arbeitsvermittlungsfirma in Wien eine Software gemacht, wo wir die Datenbank deswegen vollkommen über den Haufen werfen mussten, weil wir Dinge vorgesehen haben, die diese Datenbank nicht geleistet hat. Und wie das Produkt dann fertig war, konnten die Mitarbeiter in dieser Firma an jeder Stelle der Datenbank Notizzettel anheften. Das geht nicht, wenn man nicht ganz nach unten geht. Dazu muss man in die tiefsten inneren Strukturen von Technologie eingreifen. Wir haben bei einem Projekt mit Banken Vorschläge gemacht, wo die uns danach erklärt haben, was sie alles ändern müssten, damit das geht. Und das war schon beeindruckend, wie viele Schichten, Zwiebelschichten an alten Technologien, die da übereinander geschichtet haben. Also in Banken, in den Technologien von Banken habe ich nicht mehr wahnsinnig viel Vertrauen seitdem. Da stecken wirklich alte, alte Computer da drin.
Aber auch dieser Notizettel ist ja im Prinzip eine Kommunikationsform. Welche Rolle spielt Kommunikation bei Interaktion? Also Google Wave, ich teile da deine Ansicht, dass da eine Menge drinsteckt. Ist jetzt die Zeit gekommen, wo Interaktion auch gleichzeitig kommunikative Elemente berücksichtigt? Oder ist das jetzt ein bisschen zu weit gedacht? Oder geht es dir jetzt einfach nur um das Design der Kommunikation an der Stelle?
Nein, das ist schon eine sehr spannende Frage. Also da steckt schon was drin. Man kann natürlich jetzt, wenn ich das ein bisschen von der Seite anfangen darf, diese Frage, kann ich ein gutes Produkt als etwas sehen, das mich mit dem, was ich mache, mit den Inhalten, mit denen ich arbeite, kommunizieren lässt. In einer Art und Weise, die für mich sinnvoll ist, die eine Geschichte hat zum Beispiel. Das ist ja eh schon gemein. Wir verlieren in den elektronischen Geräten immer unsere Geschichte. Und das wäre was ganz Wichtiges. Teil von Kommunikation ist immer die Geschichte. Wenn wir Interaktion als einen Kommunikationsvorgang verstehen könnten, metaphorisch jetzt nicht so wie die...
Das ist ja auch ein schönes Ding bei Google-Wave, dass da die Geschichte auch teilt.
Dann würden wir wahrscheinlich Produkte entwickeln, die spannende neue Einblicke oder spannende neue Möglichkeiten uns eröffnen würden. Also von dem her würde ich das schon bejahen, ein bisschen anders als die Frage gemeint war. Und dann würde ich noch sagen, als eines der Dinge, wo man jetzt hinschauen sollte, weil das gerade passiert, ist das, was in Kombination mit diesen vielen Sensoren, die im iPhone drinnen sind, passiert. Es gibt eine ganz nette kleine Applikation, die heißt Pocket Universe. Die verwendet den Kompass und die Location und den Accelerometer, dazu, dass man das iPhone vor den Himmel hält und es zeigt einem, was man dort sieht. Und damit sind wir quasi dort, wo wir, das haben wir so vor zehn Jahren Augmented Reality genannt.
Also hat man damals schon angefangen so zu nennen und jetzt heißt das so.
Aber jetzt ist es da. Jetzt heißt es Pocket Universe zum Beispiel. Und das ist großartig. Da entstehen jetzt ganz schnell Dinge, wo wir alle solche großen Augen kriegen werden. Da gibt es diese lustige Applikation, wo man die Kamera dazu verwendet, um beim E-Mail schreiben schauen zu können, wo man hingeht. Hat irgendjemand gemacht. Aber es gibt auch eine Anwendung, wo man sich mit der Kamera herumdreht und er zeigt einem, wo die nächste U-Bahn-Station ist, über das Kamerabild geblendet. Eine andere Anwendung wäre, das Kamerabild zu nehmen und bestimmte Farbtöne zu kennzeichnen, um Farbenblinden die Möglichkeit zu geben, zu wissen, wo jetzt der rote Feuerlöscher ist, von dem sie suchen sollen, und nicht der gelbe oder was auch immer. Da gibt es Anwendungen, die da drinnen stecken, die noch schlummern. Weil diese Kombination von Sensoren in einem so leistungsfähigen kleinen Paket war noch nicht da. Und da wird jetzt ein, zwei Jahre lang faszinierende Dinge entstehen.
Es bleibt spannend.
Auf alle Fälle, ja. Mögest du in spannenden Zeiten leben, ist ja eigentlich ein chinesischer Fluch. Aber ich finde es gerade super.
Peter, da machen wir jetzt mal einen Punkt. Das war jetzt auch ein voluminöser, zeitlich voluminöser Ausflug. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. War so spannend, wie ich es mir erhofft hatte. Und ja, ich hoffe, ihr da draußen an den Hörgerät, ihr hattet auch euren Spaß. Und ja, über Kommentare freuen wir uns.
Genau, mich gibt es auf Twitter als Peter Pur.
Peter Pur.
Genau, also P-E-T-E-R-P-U-R. Und peter.purgathofer.net ist meine langweilige, altmodische Web 1.0-Seite. Aber das sind die internen Projekte, die nie genug Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Und mich gibt es wie immer unter Twitter Tim Pritlove und natürlich Chaosradio cccde bzw. Chaosradio etz cccde, wenn ihr wichtige Fragen habt, aber vor allem sehe ich gerne Kommentare im Blog. Blog Chaosradio cccde. Ihr wisst schon und ich hoffe, dass auch dieses Mal wieder viele kommen mit Hinweisen und Korrekturen, was nicht alles falsch gemacht haben.
Genau diese Geschichte, da gibt es viel Streit. Da kann man die Dinge auch anders sehen.
Natürlich, man kann die Dinge auch immer anders sehen und jetzt haben wir mal wieder einen neuen Einblick in eine andere Welt genommen und das war's. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.